this is jocko podcast number 277
with echo charles and me jocko willink
good evening echo good evening
it is again impressed upon every officer
and man of this command that
ground once captured must under no
circumstances be given up in the absence
of direct
positive and formal orders to do so
emanating from these headquarters
troops occupying ground must be
supported against
counter attack and all gains
held it is a favorite trick of the
germans to spread confusion
by calling out retire or fall back
if inaction any such command
is heard officers and men may be
sure that it is given by the enemy
whoever gives such a command is a
traitor
and it is the duty of any officer or man
who is loyal to his country and who
hears such an
order given to shoot the offender upon
the spot
we are not going back but forward
so came the order from major general
robert alexander on the morning of
september 26
1918 at the beginning
of the muse argonne offensive world war
one
a few days later october 1st major
charles
white whittlesey was given his orders he
was to advance
north up uh the argonne ravine
go across a brook and take
charlevoix mill and the purpose was to
get control of this mill
from which a nearby road and a nearby
rail line
could be controlled and once they had
that completed they were to push on
to hill 198 to be to complete a flanking
maneuver
on the enemy this assault
started on october 2nd
the men woke up
ate breakfast and commenced to fighting
by the evening of october 2nd
major whittlesey got reports that his
men had found a way
up he'll want 198 so they attacked
got control of the hill
got control of the hill with men from
battalions of the 307th and 308th
infantry regiments of the 154th infantry
brigade
77th division now once he got control
this hill
didn't receive any communication from
the french unit that was supposed to be
protecting his left flank and no
communication from
an american unit that was supposed to be
protecting his right flank
and it's world war one there's no radios
or anything
where the flanks had collapsed he didn't
know this but the germans had taken the
ground
wiggles lee and his men dug in
created a defensive position on that
hill which became known as the pocket
at about 22 30 that night whittles lee
realized the germans were on hill 205
and they were in the ravine off to his
right
the morning of october 3rd whittlesey
sent out
runners to his flanks to establish
communications find out where these
american and french units were
that's what you did in world war one
when you know was happening you didn't
have radios to call so you sent runners
or you sent carrier pigeons
so he sends out the runners to the left
and right flank
none of them come back
sends carrier pigeons with various
messages about their position
and situations receives no communication
back
and he comes to the realization that
they must be
completely surrounded
on the afternoon of october 3rd
the germans attacked from all sides
one of the american company commanders a
guy named captain holderman
led a breakout to try and connect with
allied forces
took massive casualties and the breakout
was
stopped so they're surrounded and stuck
and the germans attacked with mortars to
get the heads down and then got closer
and attacked with grenades
then the americans held
and as evening approached the germans
backed off
because while the germans were
assaulting not only did they cause
massive
casualties they received massive
casualties
on the morning of 4 october
the major major whittlesey was worried
that no one knew what a situation was
there was massive casualties
and then they begin getting shelled
but they begin getting shelled by their
own
artillery
and he has one last carrier pigeon left
and he launches it and this last carrier
pigeon
arrives at headquarters it's been shot
through the breast it's been blinded in
one eye and it's got one leg hanging on
by a tendon
and the message says we are along the
road parallel to
276.4 our own artillery is dropping a
barrage directly on
us for heaven's sake stop it
so the artillery stops
and then the germans attack again
and they're driven back once again and
there's
again mass casualties on both sides
except for that the americans are
running low on ammunition
they don't have any food the one water
source that they
had close by exposed them to german fire
and so this continues on the 5th and the
6th of october
attack after attack the wounded and the
dead pile up
and on the 7th of october the germans
send a
blindfolded american p.o.w forward
carrying a
white flag
and he has a note with him
and the note is directed to the
commanding officer of the americans
and it says the suffering of your
wounded men
can be heard over here in the german
lines
and we are appealing to your humane
sentiments
to stop
the white flag shown by one of your men
will tell us that you agree with these
conditions
please treat private lowell r
hollingshead the bearer of this note
as an honorable man he's quite a soldier
we envy you
signed the german commanding officer
and major widowsley allegedly replied
you go to hell
so they hunkered down and they braced
for more attacks
and then that night a relief force
arrived
and the germans finally retreated
and of the 554 troops that originally
attacked
that hill 190 were wounded
63 were missing
and 107 were killed
only 194 were able to walk out they
became known as the lost
battalion
there were seven medals of honor
awarded for this action
including one to major charles charles
w whittlesey who was immediately
promoted to lieutenant colonel
and if you are tracking the dates here
this was in october of 1918 and the war
ended
a little over a month later november
11th 1918 and this became
in america one of the most publicized
events
of the war
so the war ends in november of 1918
in 1919
there's a movie came out the movie was
called the lost battalion
whittlesley himself was in the film
playing himself
and it's a silent film you can go watch
you can see you can see him
you can see him reenacting these events
and he tried to go back to civilian life
he's now out of the army
and he's smart and he's educated and
he's
has a law degree from harvard and he had
his own
law partnership before the war
but obviously things had changed
and the one thing that had changed was
he was
you know a movie star and a hero and
there was this constant demand for
speeches and there were parades for him
and interviews and
it started to wear on him and in
november of 1921
he served as a pallbearer at the burial
of the unknown soldier at arlington
national cemetery
and a few days later he booked a trip
on a ship
from new york to havana a ship called
the
ss taloa
and he set sail on november 26th
and that night he had dinner
he chatted with some people about 11
30 that night he left for his stateroom
and in the morning the stewards
knocked on his door to go into his cabin
and no one answered so they entered his
cabin
so they could clean
and they found a note
and the note said
to the captain of the ss to loa
dear sir my name is
charles w whittlesey
14 wall street new york city
i'm enclosing some money and my watch
please give 10 to each of the deck
stewards
the room stewards and the table steward
deduct what is necessary for sending the
enclosed
wireless messages and send my balance to
my executor john
b pruin to rector street new york city
please throw my suitcases and clothes
overboard
i don't want anything returned and i'm
writing my father
that i'm making this request of you
here are the messages i would very much
appreciate you sending
one frank r whittlesey
38 pomeroy avenue pittsfield
massachusetts your son
charles willsley jumped overboard and
was drowned yesterday
he left letters for you mailed from
havana
and notifying pruin
and elisha whittlesey 2.
john b pruin to rector street new york
city charles wilson jumped overboard and
was drowned yesterday
he left a letter for you that will be
mailed from havana
i am notifying his father frank
whittlesey and his brother
elisha whittlesey
elisha whittlesey 136 east 44th street
new york city
your brother charles whittlesey jumped
overboard and was drowned yesterday
he left a letter for you that will be
mailed from havana
i am notifying your father
and john b pruin
and number four robert f little 14 wall
street new york city look in your upper
left-hand drawer of my desk
for memorandum of law matters that i've
been attending to
i shall not return
will you so kindly mail these letters i
am leaving
i'm very sorry to bother you with these
unpleasant details
signed charles w whittlesey
his body was never recovered
and they put a stone for him in the
military cemetery
in pittsfield massachusetts that reads
in memory of
charles w whittlesey lieutenant colonel
us army world war one
1884-1921
medal of honor
and that's that
our hero and a tragedy
and you can't help but ask yourself how
does this
happen
how does the story of heroism and
camaraderie
and courage how does that turn into a
story of despair
and loneliness and loss of hope
and what can we learn from that story
how can we learn to avoid
that tragedy
and move away from the darkness and move
toward the light
and here tonight to discuss that with us
is one of the few people in the world
that can have some semblance of
understanding of that story
of what colonel whittlesey went through
his name is dakota meyer and if you
don't know who he is then just stop
listening right now and go listen to
podcast number 115.
dakota meyer is a marine he's a sniper
he's a father
he's a recipient of the medal of honor
he's one of my heroes and most
importantly he's one of my friends
dakota
thanks for coming down man thanks for
having me
man that's uh um
that you know that hits home
you know i was listening to the last
time you were on this podcast
and we we basically kind of closed
it out after you received the medal of
honor i mean we went just a little bit
past it
but you know since then
well you know you and i have talked
about things that are going on and
what it was like after that and you know
as i
and as i read through that story
of colonel wigglesley you can see
there's there's
there's definite parallels oh i mean
it's
uh yeah i mean like i like while you
were reading it like i
um i mean like i was like
tearing up because like i like i could
just
i could feel how lonely that guy was
you know it's uh
yeah i mean you know
how do you
yeah i mean there's like what do you do
the rest of your life
you know like what do you what do you do
the rest of your life you're like yeah
you can keep going and giving back
but it's also a lonely road because
you know everybody's sitting here
just first off you don't know why
they're around you
you know and then you don't know and
everybody loves to just
like they just want to watch you fail
you know what i mean so that they can in
their mind
make themselves feel better and it's
like everything you do is criticized
and i just i mean just with how that guy
did it it's just
he he did it on his terms you know it's
like it's
it's a yeah i mean it's a it's a lonely
road
i mean it's a lonely road and it's not
just uh
it's not just yeah i mean
i'm nothing special i don't look at
myself as anything
as anything special i did what i trained
to do i did
what i put hope into to people to do if
they were in that situation
but you know it's just and it's i
and honestly i think it's even worse
today with everybody being able to
to to to watch how you live your life
like more people have their eyes on you
right
like like you know you get a guy who
goes out and
deals with ptsd or whatever he's
struggling that day
i mean i'm scared like i won't even go
like i remember
when i call my doctors if i need to go
talk to somebody a therapist or
something like i come up with a route of
how i can go in the back door so nobody
sees me so that they can publicize oh
look
look there's dakota going like there's
something wrong with him you know what i
mean like
it's just uh the the the standards are
not
they're not the ground's not equal now
and it's just uh
yeah i mean but also like you you get
you get a choice every day is a choice
and it's like am i going to take this
and
try to give back and continue using the
things that made me successful in that
moment
and apply it somewhere else you know
like the most fulfillment i get is my
daughters
and and whenever i'm trying to help
people as a firefighter like it's been
the best
thing for me like i i'll i'll never
forget i um
there's this guy and i i talk about in
the book there was this was one of the
first times i felt
if i felt real again almost and
i'd helped this guy and he didn't know
who i was
he didn't know me for what i'd done he
didn't know my name
i was just a guy in a uniform and there
when he needed help
and he like thanked me and was so
appreciative and i was like that feels
good
that feels good he didn't have any
any assumption of who i was or how i was
you know what i mean like that guy just
needed that moment and i could be there
for him
and it shows me that i still got it that
i still got it
you know because i mean you get off and
like how long do you get out of the
military
we've talked about this how long do you
get out of the military
and you can still you can still walk
around
with this i'm a warrior but you haven't
even had to get in the ring
how long does that credibility still
give you i'm a warrior
today not i was a warrior but i am a
warrior how long do you get that
credibility without getting in the ring
you know and it's always a struggle
that's always a struggle is
do i still have it could i still do it
could i still perform at that level
because at the day you can't
you have to say i was a warrior
you know mm-hmm and it's like
yeah i mean you have to be tested and
that's the one thing you talk david
godkins like that guy
he tests himself all the time he's
always pushing it
but but that's like yeah i mean that's
the struggle is it's like
could i steal like and like it the
further i get away from that day in
afghanistan
you know like i question myself all the
time of
did i how could i have done that that
day but like
today i don't today i can't even
you know get myself to have enough
discipline to go work out
what happened to me do you know
so when you get
when you get done like how long did it
take for the
for the damn ceremonies and the round of
interview i remember i remember you and
i were talking on the phone
i forget when but you were talking about
like
you were on 60 minutes you were on all
the like every what freaking letterman
you did everything yeah how long did
that did that
last for you know like i was i was like
it was really crazy all the way all the
way up to i got it in
september 15th of 2011.
through december it was crazy i mean i
was on the view
60 minutes cbs sunday morning fox all
the time i was on
um uh obviously letterman um
jay leno i mean you guys look at
everything you look down down the list
and it was i mean it was crazy i mean it
was crazy
and um it's still like speeches kept
going like i mean you
still walk out places and people
recognize you and you know everybody's
coming at you and wanting you and this
and that and
and it was it took me like i hated it i
was i mean i when i hear people say hey
i met you
back in two but anytime i'm like when
did you meet me if it was between 2011
and 2014
um i apologize first thing i said is i'm
sorry i'm sorry
i was drunk the whole time i hated it
like i hated it
like there would be times that like so i
had a whole team around me
the marine corps sent like right after
they announced i was getting the medal
the marine corps sent out like seven
people to live with me 24
7. what were they like
what were they doing i had like i had a
security guy
that stayed in my house like he stayed
with
i never like i wasn't anywhere by myself
for
probably 90 days at least 120 days
and a guy live a guy lived with me um
they sent in like there were pr people
pao people like there was three of them
um
and you're 23 years old i'm 23 years old
i was tying steel
there's there's there's interviews you
go on the internet
and there's interviews um so they sent
divots out right so like the
dod the marine corps like combat camera
people like
capturing this there are images of like
i got refused i'm like no
it's not changing my life and i'm
literally on a skid steer like working
under a skid steer and they're
interviewing me because
they had to get something and i would
not stop i'm like no you can follow me
but that's it so they would get up and
follow me to go work at
yards and stuff all day long but yeah i
mean so i had all that and
i mean it was just like a you know my
whole life changed and
and then you know it like everything was
good it's like they built me up
like i was i couldn't do anything wrong
and it's like when they got you the top
of the mountain it was like the pinata
they raise up
and then it was just like here came the
media just as soon as you said something
wrong or
i mean they were just it's the gotchas
and it was like it was like they just
built you up to just try to smash you
down right and there was always this one
reporter who was there
um that just always wanted to take me a
task so it's like you just got you had
to you just start
you take these beatings right and and
like it does like people are like oh who
cares
who cares what they say about you
well there's only one thing i've got in
this life and that's my name and
reputation
that's the only like when i die on my
tombstone
it's not going to have any of my awards
it's not going to have anything but the
day i was born
and the day i died and it's going to say
mire
at the top of it and that's what people
are gonna know
that's my brand and so i took it serious
like when i would come home and
i remember i landed one night and uh
i landed real late in louisville and i
was driving home
and the courier journal had
released on the front page across the
state because i remember i pulled into
this
gas station in my hometown and it was
across the state and it was medal of
dishonor
with my page on the front page of the
state paper right
and they were trying to discredit
everything that i'd done and
it was so bad that like my friends got
up like they found out about it
and they got up and they went and bought
all the papers out
in town and it was just always something
man
and it's just like you you just can't
there's no rhyme or reason to it you
know and and it's just a
yeah i mean it you get isolated so i get
i get what that guy said you know what
that guy did
um because i mean sometimes you just
you know what if i can't help people and
make a difference what am i doing
what are you doing so you say the
like the hype train lasted from
september
to december i mean at some point does
all of a sudden those seven marines that
were there watching every move all
sudden like their
their duties over we got mired done with
whatever you need to get done
yeah and then like one day you wake up
and like get along
yeah so we were supposed to go to so we
did a east coast
west coast and we're supposed to hawaii
tour so it's like
we were like a weekend in new york
and then a week in california and then
we were supposed to go to hawaii for
like a week to do
press and all this right see the bases
and
do the press on each coast and we went
to new york
did that so like i got the medal came
home
and then the week after that i was this
is when all this started
and uh by the time i hit california i'm
like i'm out
like i on the plane to california from
new york to california i said i can't
i'm out i can't keep doing this um
and so that was it like what was it that
made you feel you could you like
did the people just constantly talking
to you i mean was it just you feel like
you're put up on a pedestal and we
talked about this the first time you're
on here
i mean basically everyone's saying hey
good job i mean you got to take this
like
i am literally known
for the biggest failure of my life
like you you can't change the narrative
to
like like that's where people get wrong
is they're like well like they
justify stuff in their head the facts
are this
like you can't change the facts all my
team is dead
like i didn't get them out whether
whether it was rational or not
somebody can say i'm going to do 10 000
push-ups today
and they're trying to break a guinness
book a world record nobody looks at him
and says well you you did
you did 500 an hour that's that's good
enough they failed
i failed my teammates are dead
their families has unanswered questions
there's
you know there's there's four kids that
don't ever see their dad
and i'm getting paraded around the
nation
as a hero and
it's like i look at all these other
metal like all the other medal of honor
guys and
and i i'm away from them because you
know
i get look kyle carpenter i couldn't
imagine what that kid gone through like
you talk about a guy that's a warrior
that kid's a warrior
i don't have anything like that and
but i tell these i tell these guys that
like
you guys you guys did some badass stuff
you guys did badass stuff
and you got some guys to enjoy it with
i come home i ain't got anybody
and it's literally the biggest failure
of my life now with that i've learned a
lot
but i can't change the narrative because
it doesn't feel
and you started you started feeling this
way while you're flying from new york to
california
like i mean i i told the president that
i couldn't accept the medal i wanted him
to break it down to a navy cross
i told him i couldn't accept the medal
because like he said you're a hero i'll
never forget
president obama told me that i was a
hero and i said
if you think i'm such a hero why don't
you call my teammates up
and get their opinion go let them know
i'm a hero
and i'm not and that's why like
that's why when these people are like
trying to discredit or they're trying to
say oh you know
whatever i mean i can't argue with them
i i
like you talk about getting my ass
kicked like i got a medal of honor for
getting my ass kicked
and so i just i couldn't keep living
this
in the media of like it just it was it
was a hard thing like
i just wasn't there yet right now i
don't do it about me i do it about my
teammates
right like i do it to try to show these
lessons of if hey
you know i come to this point to where i
wasn't going to change it
i wasn't going to be able to get away
from it you know it was like
and so how do i use it to make a
difference how do i try to turn
something
so terrible into something good and
that's what i
ended up having to do but yeah i got off
like on the plane to it was on the plane
la it was on the plane from new york to
la and i remember looking at the girl
who was running all my stuff
she was she's a rock star you talk about
a girl who
she is a rock star and um
i said i we we're done we're done we'll
finish these interviews here but we're
not going to hawaii
and i'm going home and landed
we did the stuff we had doing in la i
flew home from there
and then um i mean i was still doing
events and still doing what people
wanted me to i was i had a scholarship
fund with the marine corps scholarship
foundation
i had this challenge to america where we
would raise a million dollars to put
kids to
college so like i was going out speaking
at events for that to
like going to private dinners to where
somebody would write a huge check to
to the scholarship foundation so i was
doing that and then
yeah no i didn't have any nobody taught
me
what i should do what i shouldn't do you
know they it was like uh
23 years old just thrown to this
machine that i mean i didn't even have
an instagram at the time
right like i didn't i didn't know what
to do and um so yeah i mean i did that i
was on the speaking like i did speaking
with leading authorities
um broke my book with being west in 2012
and you know like speeches kept going
and like events and things like that
and um but just kind of just kind of
going with the flow of
what's next right and yeah
i did see what was the marine corps when
you said hey look i'm not going to
hawaii we're i'm done
i'm done was the marine corps thinking
or did anybody say
okay hey maybe we need to give
dakota some like help to get through
this
because he's got a massive amount of
guilt over what happened
did anybody talk to you along those
lines at all so the marine corps didn't
know what to do either
right like i was the first living marine
since vietnam
to receive the medal of honor so they
weren't really schooled up on it either
and um there was one mistake that they
made
uh and from the beginning is
um and they tried to put it together but
when they put the narrative together
this is what opened us up to the media
to the the um
the guy who actually was the reporter
that was actually the one that
just was trying to discredit everything
and this was his heart
this is a piece he honed on but like in
the in the first
initial write-up they had to do right
they put numbers in of how many people
were rescued
or say whatever you want to call it and
how many people i killed
which opened it up
to numbers which a doesn't matter
and b opens it up right because it
doesn't really matter did you did you
kill
28 people or 72 people or 172 people
it's like it's all it doesn't really
matter
right right did you save because you can
get a medal of honor for saving one
person
you can get a medal of honor for killing
one person yeah
you can get a medal of honor for saving
100 or killing 100 it's that's not what
it's about
but if they open it up for that all of a
sudden they make it matter
and that's and that was where it messed
up and i think like there started
that the negative stuff started coming
out and
that was where but like the reporter
even says in his article there's an
article out there about like well
there's quite a few
but he even states he goes um he was
um he states all these things these
discrepancies but he goes
i'm not saying he doesn't deserve it i
actually read that article
yesterday yeah he said he says something
along the lines of
not that these actions alone don't fully
warrant the medal of honor yeah
so what the hell are you doing
so it's those things that like you know
a guy like me and like you
you have you've had to talk me down a
guy like me all i've known my whole life
like i'm not there's only one thing i'm
good at and it's fighting
it's all i know like i have been
it's all i know you know what i mean
like it's the only thing that's made me
successful at anything is that i was
willing to fight
and i was willing to work and
you put those things
in a spot where there's there's people
who are poking
it's not a good it's not a good thing
right
and and so like i had to back up you
know get myself together
i was drinking too much like i was just
trying to deal with all of it i mean i
mean imagine walking into a room and
everybody wants to talk to you about
the worst day of your life
like over and over and over
and it's like you don't have to it's not
about going home and not dreaming about
it it's about i'm
walking into rooms and i'm sitting here
literally
reliving it over and over and over
which which is is okay
um but i just i just think that like
sometimes the worst day of my life is
somebody else's entertainment
i wish i would have pulled this quote um
major whittlesey he was at like a dinner
and spoke at the dinner he sits down
with his friends and they
the friends were talking they said
something along the lines of he said
exactly what you just said exactly what
you just said he said something along
the lines of
every time i talk about this i go right
back there
and i can't get away from it yeah
yeah like yeah yeah i mean i just
i mean look i'm i still today i miss my
guys
i mean you know i i just seen that one
of my like
one of my teammates his his daughter's a
you know she's about to have a baby and
you know you just
it's just it's crazy you know i mean
it's like i get to sit here and enjoy my
two beautiful daughters who are
more than i ever deserve i get to i get
to hang around such amazing people and i
get to live
a beautiful life and and all these
things
and you know it's just it's not
it's not a fair world you know
it's not and that's that was always the
thing you know struggle for me to deal
with and
you know how do you give back how do you
continue to give back right like what
look i mean yeah
how do you get back right so yeah so
like the marine corps left they went on
their own way
honestly they kind of separated from me
i didn't hear much from them again
uh probably two and a half two two and a
half years
i didn't hear much from them it was like
mission complete for them
it was like hey let's separate from this
because i don't know if this thing's
going to be a hand grenade or
you know what's going to happen isn't it
weird you know
you said earlier like for for this guy
you said it's worse today right because
everyone there's you know
word travel so fast and all this stuff
but you would
think man like at least people
understand the concept
of survivor guilt and post traumatic
stress like at least we understand those
things
and yet it seems like you know if i
when someone goes through something like
this you gotta like give them some
support
you know yeah yeah i mean
yeah but but you know like how do you do
that when everybody looks at you like a
hero
you do how many times have you been in a
situation with
with a group of people knowing damn well
that you all you are all as scared as it
gets
and but it's like as long as you keep
your poker face on
you could literally be the thing that
breaks them where everybody's gonna be
like
no you just confirmed their fears
or you you are the thing that keeps them
going
and and you know
i i just always took it as
this is my um
i got the medal and that's my punishment
for letting my teammates get killed this
is my punishment to be
paraded in front of all the people
as a hero the exact opposite of what i
am
and that was that was my punishment that
was what
the universe or god whoever you want to
think about it this was
this was what i got for failing that day
and that was that was kind of how it was
you know
and so like anytime i got to give a
speech or talk to people and tell them
the realities of it
you know i just wanted them to know that
hey look you can get your ass kicked and
get back up from it
and that's what the story is my story is
not a story of
a guy who is some high speed low drag
you know my story is a story of a guy
who
got his ass kicked and has had his ass
kicked his whole life and has
has who who lives a life of success
he has found a way to make success out
of a [ __ ] ton of failures
and that's kind of that's kind of what
it is you know
but yeah the marine corps went away and
then i started hiring my own people
when you say hiring your own people kind
of people so like i had
i had agents right so i had a book agent
a book and movie agent
with icm sloan sloane harris was a great
guy
i had you know obviously with the
speaking agency
i had i had security people like that i
would keep on me
and not really for anything other than
to protect me from myself
right like because you know i walked in
i mean i would walk in somewhere and
like
we'd be drinking and somebody would say
something i would hit them
and you know what that's a lawsuit now
you know what i mean
um i had you know assistants i mean you
know
people who would kind of handle me to
get me to where i need to be
i mean it was it was it was a crazy it
was a crazy time
i mean it was crazy and um
that was all the way up until probably
2014 and then
and then it just i kind of just i was
like i just want to get away from it
and i started backing off and you know i
was so fortunate that i've been with
toyota since 2011
and you know you talk about ed laucas
and you talk about don
esmen and you talk about like all these
these incredible people inside of toyota
like these people's like met me and um
they've mentored me the whole way like
you talk about sticking with me through
thick and thin and
believing in a cause of of of
you know of helping veterans and just
like you take them out of out of you
know if i hadn't met them in 2000
you know 2012 there's no time where i'd
be
so those guys were kind of helping you
guide you through all this
and former marines uh so don esman was
a marine he was in vietnam a pilot in
vietnam he was a medevac pilot
so he's got over 900 missions shot down
silver star recipient i mean
but he was um he was the uh
i think he was the ceo of toyota
and um we you know i i
got in contact with them and they
brought me on as they were they they got
with this
program called hiring our heroes that i
work with and helping veterans get back
to work and
and um but but it was more personal for
them
it wasn't a business thing for them like
they took me in and then
uh you know ed laucas his mom and dad
both were in world war ii
and uh marines and so it was just like
it was crazy how i got there to them
and they you know gosh you talk about
2011 2012 dakota yeah
yeah is that when you were the hand
grenade that the marine corps was scared
you were
listen you you take those people out of
my life you know john lisco
and they didn't have to do it and you
know you just find these people
yeah you know i when you say these
people like helped you out
i there's always people that ask me
um hey how can we help veterans and you
know it's really easy to say like give
to charity which is awesome for sure
but in terms of what what
is helpful and what you're talking about
is like actually form relationships
with people so that you can see where
you can help them and you can provide
them the help and support that they need
yeah there's a big difference between me
writing a check and saying okay i feel
better about myself because i wrote a
check to whatever foundation which again
that's good
but if you want to go next level form
some relationships with some people
and look veterans have especially like
you like me when i was young
right you have no i didn't really have
any experience in the world right i was
institutionalized
it was just i just knew the military
that's me that's my life
so if i would have gotten out when i was
23 24 years old i wouldn't know what to
do
so someone that's a civilian that's a
little older if you form a relationship
with someone
and look i can tell you it's not going
to be easy oh no
i can almost guarantee that being trying
to mentor and guide
23 year old dakota there's gonna be
challenges like
it's like having a freaking teenage boy
that's old enough to drink and has money
yeah
yeah yes yeah and and that was it right
like
you know it you talk about ed i mean i
go but i keep talking about ed larkis
and like
you talk about a guy who just i mean he
was like i mean he was like a second dad
you know what i mean like he
you know his wife karen just i mean i
actually i just called her mom you know
and you talk about any any i mean just
they went out of their way and i was so
lucky but
you know that's the one thing that i
have to say if i've ever been good at
you know all the way growing up i've
always been able to find
um great like i've always had this
way of finding great people and and
knowing who good people were
who i should try to be like i was really
good at figuring those out
and in making them believe in me right
like i was
that that's the only that's the only
power i really have is
is that i can i know who i who's who's
really good in the room and who's
who's who i should be like and i find a
way
to get them to help get me there and
then
always having great mentors i've had
that from day one
um i've been i've been so fortunate to
have that right
and that's what's got me i mean even
still today even still today that's the
pieces that keep me
going and keep getting me better and
keep helping me grow and learn and
develop you know and that's
that's been my key to to to success or
whatever you call it to still being here
right
um is those people you know i'm just a
i'm just a product of the people who
who are around me they should get the
credit for any successes i have
you know and that's how it is
so when you when you uh in the book in
into the fire you you
i mean you had the lowest of low points
right you're in your freaking truck and
and you're you basically try and kill
yourself but
luckily someone uh
pulled a round out of the pulled around
out of the chamber so
your your weapon wasn't chambered round
wasn't chambered
then you get the medal then you're on
like a there's a little lift you're
getting the metal you're getting all
this attention
do you go back down to a low point at
some point
yeah yeah i mean i mean i think like if
yeah yeah i mean it's it's always like a
it's like a roller coaster i mean i
don't know what it causes it
you know what i mean like there's some
days i wake up and i'm just like man i
don't want to get out of bed
like i don't even want to get out of bed
and um
why i don't know but yeah i mean after i
got the medal i was in the lowest
of lowes i mean it was the lowest of
lows
i mean it was just i would literally
like i'll never forget this one time it
was actually going to my speaking agency
well you you talk about the day the the
president called me to come have a beer
with him
like where i was standing i can remember
i was standing
speaking to some marines um i won't say
where
but i was speaking to some marines at an
event and i
mean i was hammered my kid was probably
9 10 a.m in the morning and i'm not
talking about like buzzed i'm talking
about like
dakota was drunk um i would get up in
the morning before
interviews like the six five six a.m
interviews and i'd be taking shots
on the way to the studio um
and like i was standing there and i'll
never forget like whenever
they said for me to come over and have a
drink um
this so the girl who used to take care
of me her name is jeanette
jeannette looked at me and like her face
like melted
she's like i hope they don't give you
sobriety tests before you go in like we
have to sober you up she literally
started making me pound
waters to try to get me sober enough to
go into the white house
and i mean that was how i lived like i
just i couldn't like i hated i couldn't
take it you know and
i mean i could but i just i just hated
what it was about
it wasn't about the work or about the
workload it was just i was literally
just living
this this nightmare and um
you know they were rock stars and uh but
yeah i mean
i was a [ __ ] show so how
how long did you stay in that mode for
probably until like 2014. and then what
what happened in 2014 did you did you
realize something
what happened um i just i stayed like
i kind of i kind of seen that like i
needed to get my [ __ ] together
um you know i was going out and i kind
of had a turn of
like i look i wasn't going to be able to
change it like i wasn't going to be able
i realized i wasn't going to be able to
outdrink it
and how do i turn into something
positive right and i i just
i had this dream to be able to somebody
asked me one time they're like what what
do you want to do and i'm like
honestly i just want to change the world
and i know it sounds crazy right it
sounds so crazy but
when i when i looked real deep into
why have i done like the stuff i did in
afghanistan
you know like i didn't do it
for me i didn't do it everything i did
was
ultimately down of trying to make the
world that i was part of just a little
bit better
like like anytime i handed out
soccer balls to the kids or i went out
front of the gate
you know i was just trying to make their
day a little bit better show them a
different perspective
when i was when i was taking a shot and
i was trying to take a guy out or i was
going in and they were asking for help
and
hey we need security in this in this
village to help us out the taliban's
doing this or that
i literally just wanted to make the
world just a little bit better
and if if that's truly my core purpose
why i can do that here it's no different
one of the things that i've been talking
about in a bunch of different ways
lately is this idea of being caught in
like an echo chamber in a feedback loop
and you hear it
in the social media world because if
you're a super liberal person you just
see a bunch of super liberal stuff if
you're a super conservative person you
just see a bunch of conservative stuff
it happens in a leadership position
because if you're in a leadership
position and
you have an idea and everyone just is a
yes man then says yup yup yeah you're
great boss that sounds like a great idea
and you go forward
you're only hearing you don't get any
other input yeah
and it happens to people's mentalities
too
where you know they have a bad day and
then
they think well today was so bad and
tonight's going to be bad too and then
tomorrow's going to be bad and i don't
they they get caught in this echo
chamber
of of reinforcing the same
thoughts over and over again and that's
fine if they're good
thoughts but when it's a negative
thought and just like you know when you
do feedback with a microphone into an
amplifier right it just
turns into a freaking squeal and you
can't get out of it
until you either shut that thing off or
you get that microphone away
so you know you were it sounds like you
were in that
mode but then you thought to yourself
you know it's a pretty what you just
said of like realizing
hey i can't change it why did i do it
what can i do to move forward like
that's a huge
step away from oh it's it's it's a it
takes a lot of strength
to break out of this negative attitude
and what sucks is you meet people
and they're freaking trapped in there
and it's
it's i don't know i don't know
if you can actually manually
i don't know if i can manually go to you
and say hey you're in an echo chamber
right now and get you out of it
yeah i think sometimes i i think it may
be that the person has to do that for
themselves
well i always say like you you can
either
like sometimes um
sometimes you find yourself in the
middle of nowhere in the middle of
nowhere
and sometimes in the middle of nowhere
you find yourself
and um
yeah i mean i think what's even what's
even more dangerous is when you start
drinking your own kool-aid
right like like when you're not looking
at everybody
else and kind of getting a feeling off
of it and then you surround yourself
with a bunch of yes people
like like and then you and then you only
get that you start drinking your own
kool-aid
i mean what happens like yeah you can
live off of in a survival situation
drinking your own urine but what happens
if you drink it five times over
it's that you're dead it's all you know
and and i think that's dangerous yeah
well actually it's the same
it's the same mechanism it's just a
different one's one's positive one's
negative if you go and just positive
positive positive
you'll spin out and you'll think you
can't be stopped and you think you can
do nothing wrong
if it's negative negative negative you
don't think you can do anything right
and the reality is for everybody
we do something right we do something
wrong we make some mistakes we we have
some wins we
we have some losses we move forward we
take a couple steps back we move forward
again
but people that think oh every step i
take is going to move me forward and
everyone's you know everyone's following
me because i'm awesome
or nothing i can do can move me forward
it's not that's not the way life is it's
not one or the other it's both
and people get stuck there in one or the
other
um you know i think the negative one is
the one that
looked a positive one it seems like
you what happens with the positive one
is when you fall off that train you at
least
you fall onto you have a little distance
to fall and you're gonna be okay you
have like enough room to pull your
reserve
yeah when you're at the bottom you're
already on you're you're on your reserve
and you burn in and that's what i was on
right like i just
it was just everything was negative
around me the alcohol i mean it was just
everything was negative right i mean i'm
waking up literally talk only talking
about my teammate's death
and um i mean it was just everything was
negative i mean it was
and i um
you know i i just had to pull myself out
of it i don't i don't know of one
situation that just like
boom smacked me out of it um
i will say this like ultimately the the
one of the biggest changing points in my
life was when i had my daughter
um that was
that was whenever the drinking quit like
that was whenever i took
it and i said
i said you know what it's not about me
um
i know i'm not the best person in the
world and
you know i i but i'll tell you this my
daughter didn't choose to come in this
world
she didn't choose to come in the
circumstances that she came in under
and it is my obligation to ultimately
give her
and wake up every day and strive to be
the father that that young girl deserves
and that's it it really is that simple
and so that was whenever the drinking
just
went to a halt um but then there was a
whole slew of problems after that right
of
now i'm not dealing with my anxiety or
my issues with drinking
now they're coming to light so you know
now it was kind of having to face
the true reality of this not not not
taking the band-aid
i mean drinking is no different than
taking anti it
pills i mean it's a painkiller it's just
another it's just another form of it
right
and um so that was a whole other problem
but
but i got to look at that little girl
and like that was
that is you know sailor and atlee are by
far
um i need them way more than they could
ever need me
you know what i mean like and
and they changed my life for the better
and they still do every day
um because ultimately that's what
the man that i am i i have to be a good
man because
i want my daughters to find good men and
i want them to know what a good man
looks like
and i want if they start dating shitty
guys someday it's probably because i'm a
shitty guy
i want to set the example to them of
hopefully what they strive to go
to go find and marry someday
and i have to wake up and be that
yeah that's weird from uh um being in
the military
the perspective for me because i was you
know a young enlisted guy i was going to
say young dumb
and yes i was a young dumb enlisted guy
and
the the more i moved up in the ranks all
of a sudden you're like
responsible for people
and those was no overnight like
transition for me
you know because i was enlisted and then
i became an officer and i was a junior
officer but i
i it wasn't like i wanna i'm an officer
now and now i need to or uh
you know i'm in charge of this training
event and so i need to
no it wasn't like an overnight thing but
i realized
that hey all these guys are counting on
me to do it do my job
to to make good decisions to give them
the support that they need like that's
all on me all on me 100
and so slowly over time i i started
acting more and more like a freaking
responsible human
instead of like a complete freaking
savage
when i was a freaking younger teen guy
yeah
and so i just got you know i just you
know grew
and then obviously yeah when i had kids
it's like oh
now there's people that also uh
rely on me 100 for everything
for everything and they're looking at me
as an example
of how they should be acting and what
they should be looking for
yeah yeah it's big
so you did you stopped drinking like
yeah i mean cold turkey i did
um when sailor when sailor was born
um i pretty much i mean i pretty much
cut it out to cold turkey
um yeah i mean i
i mean i was like yeah i mean i was i
had to
i mean i was like i was in a custody
battle first off so out of the gate
i mean i wasn't even i mean i wasn't
yeah i mean yeah i wasn't there when
sailor was born
and um i got to meet her like three
months later
and uh so you know with the custody
battle it was
look i'll take 90 of it my fault me and
bristol didn't get along
um she was she went back to alaska what
didn't work out right and so i wasn't
there for the
the the birth
[Music]
and uh so finally after three months of
fighting and all the stuff that people
do right
and look i'm sure i caused my amount of
it so let me say that up front
i'm definitely not an easy person to
live with um
you know i finally got to meet her
and i'll never forget like i flew up
i flew up on an airplane so first off
after i've seen
realized that sailor was born i went it
was on it was on 23rd
or she was born on the 23rd and so
christmas that year was 20
christmas eve was on a thursday and
christmas was on friday that year and um
i went up that saturday as soon as the
stores opened back up
and i i went ahead and bought like all
of her stuff to have in my house i
didn't know when i get to see her or
anything like that
if she'd ever even get to come to
kentucky but like i was a dad so i was
going to be a dad
and um i had no clue of how to change a
diaper or anything
and then i went to this month-long it's
it's like an online nanny school and i
became a certified nanny and infant care
specialist um
so i was like doing these classes i was
doing these classes right like of
um how to swaddle like learning about
all these things that
kids do right and i mean i just never
wanted to
it wasn't my daughter's fault so like i
never wanted to not be what she needed
if she needed it and so like i needed to
spend my
my mindset was i needed to you know i'm
a dad and i need to try to
if i even if i'm not with her i need to
be training
to do something to be able to to to give
her the life that she deserves
and um man three months into it i got to
meet her and so i
i fly up there and what i would do is i
would fly to alaska every year i'm gonna
put this training to the test yeah to
the test like i had all this stuff
like man like i knew like the five s's
of like
what you know how to get a child to like
you know to calm down like all this
stuff i was a master
i had this like little baby doll that i
used to swaddle practicing right
crazy i know it's nuts
so so i fly up there
and uh so i would fly to alaska every
other weekend
and i would um raise her for four days
out of a hotel room
a three-month-old and from kentucky
and so i go up there and i got her man
the first time i laid eyes on her
that was it like i got on the plane
coming home after those four days
and i just said hey i'm getting rid of
everything in kentucky and i even if i
just have to work at mcdonald's i'm
going to alaska and i'm going to raise
this kid
um i don't want anything else i don't
want another life i don't want anything
else
i don't care if i just if i just have to
live in a cardboard box on the side of
the road i'm going to raise this kid and
i'm going to
i'm going to be the best dad that i can
be and
that's why i started figuring out right
i went home and literally started
looking at assets of how to
how to close everything down and leave
and um
yeah so that was kind of that's kind of
that and i just go up there
and then after that you know like a
little ways into it we stopped fighting
and
me and bristol decided to get married
and we got married and
you know i had another kid and
then it went to [ __ ] and and all this
stuff
uh you you were this is like tabloid
tabloid material yeah this is just
tabloid material
too yeah so you yeah like if you look at
the tabloids now
like uh they don't refer to me as a
medal of honor recipient they refer to
me as bristol palin's ex
so you guys get married which
you know you're doing the best you can
you know people do what they're gonna do
you're trying to figure things out
yeah i mean we tried look i mean
bristol's not a bad person you know
she's
um she's the mother of my children she
gave me the most beautiful things in the
world like my kids are healthy they're
beautiful
they are they're the best thing that i
have
um and i owe her for that i owe her for
for all that you know um i'm not an easy
person to live with like let me tell you
like i'm i'm not um so yeah so we got we
got our beautiful kids so where did you
move once you got once you guys got
married
so i i we
we got married and i literally packed up
two suitcases and left for alaska and i
never came home
i just moved in with her and i would fly
to the states just as i was on going to
give speeches across
you know canada lived up there for a
year and then we moved to
um austin and how are you doing like at
that point
are you starting to sort of uh
process everything that happened are you
starting to be like
okay these people are calling me a hero
but i have an opportunity to be able to
explain to them my perspective of it
were you starting to kind of put this
together in a way that was more
manageable for you
no i mean it's still not right because
everybody wants to argue with me
you know it's like no no like understand
i'm a failure
oh no you did everything you could
like shut up you know what i mean like
no it's still that way
you know and it's it's just
no it's still not it's still not back
you know people still they hold me in
this regard that i'm like that i'm
like that i'm something that i'm i'm not
i'm no different than anybody else
you know i was listening to something
you said you i was listening to uh
your podcast actually and you were
saying
something along the lines of hey you
know i i received the medal of honor but
i don't want to let that define me i
don't want that to be like the thing
that i'm known for
and i started thinking to myself you you
and me know how freaking completely
random
war is like the you don't know what the
hell is going to happen
there's nothing way to predict anything
you could have done that deployment
you that mission could have got scrubbed
for 10 000 reasons that night
it could have gone and the taliban could
have not been there there's like a
million things there's
and and so really there's a roll of the
dice that you
were in this situation the way it went
down you didn't get killed
you know like it's just it's so random
that if you
did hang your hat on that one thing it's
like that's like saying hey
that's like that's like i won the lotto
yeah
so you should you know that means i'm
smart or whatever like you know it's it
you can't let me pick your numbers for
all your lottery tickets
you know what i mean yeah yeah so i was
thinking about that like you can't let
it define you because if you do let it
define you then you're you're
you're defining yourself on the fact
it's like it's like defining yourself on
you know how tall you are yeah it's like
hey you know that's just
how tall you are there's nothing you can
do about that now look obviously you
took actions that
that were a conscious decision to go do
and what you had to do
but you're right in the fact that if you
let that one thing define you
you're hanging your hat on on something
that's kind of random well
exactly right but it's also i mean it's
also like
um like what if
what if like a fighter gets in the ring
and he
he gets a win i mean whether like he got
a knockout and it was one hit and it was
i mean are those hits lucky right i mean
you know what i mean like like could you
can you really walk into a ring
and say you're gonna like and and knock
people you know i mean like
some of that is the same right some of
it is
this guy just he if he didn't break this
or you know i mean like
that's why the games are played right
that's why
football teams are not fantasy you know
what i mean like that's why the game
is played and um
so like for me it was like yeah that day
that day i like if it comes down to
fighting like i fought my ass off
there's
i'll say that um
i fought as hard as i could uh
but that was one day of my life what
about the rest of them
you know like that day's done that's
behind me well what's next
right like i mean i was in a gun fight
four days later that that i felt like
was worse than that one
you know what i mean obviously i lost my
teammates which sucked
but as far as like i mean
the odd the next one was was was a
harder one for me to pick out than than
the first one right
and and nobody knows about that i mean i
still kept fighting we we've gotten a
ton of fights after that
and and so like you just can't be
defined by that you know you're only as
good as as your next at bad and it's
like you can't
you can't let your failures define you
and you can't let your successes define
you both of them are nothing more than
moments in time
yeah that that's that was kind of my
um i don't want to call it a setup but
like
it's one thing it's funny right and even
though you feel like oh i failed that
night it's like yeah that's that was
one that was one thing i did and so to
say
you don't want to define yourself by
receiving this one award
it's also you can't define yourself by
by the fact that
that day you didn't win exactly but it
still doesn't change
the results of the day right like and at
the end of the day
those have all taught me valuable
lessons
you know they're you can't
like and and
hear me out on this but like life is
nothing more
than like a uh and you're gonna laugh
when i define it when i say this
life is nothing more than before you
know like you know like at halloween
they have those we're off to a good
start okay scary houses right or those
those
those whatever those houses that haunted
houses haunted houses right
you can call them scary houses whatever
so
life is like that's life after you've
walked through that haunted house once
does it get you again no so that's life
right
like life is full of these things that
are not
real that scare us because we've never
seen them
or we've never seen them in that place
or whatever right we wasn't expecting it
coming there so it kind of
shakes us for a second but you got one
or two options
after you've seen it you can either oh
okay
i got it you're there you got me on that
one but if i walk through this house
again you don't have me right
and that in that life like that's life
right and um
you know so like that day i got the cool
part is is like that's my that day is my
kryptonite
um i'm not going to say that i could
never see anything worse because
i i i obviously it could always be worse
but
man at 21 21
i got to walk through one of the
scariest damn houses
that life could throw at me i'm gonna
tell you right now
i got i got to sit here and look death
right in the eyes
i never thought i i i never thought i
would make it out
i got to look at that so i don't have to
worry about every day is a bonus day for
me i didn't think i was going to live
past
september 8 2009. i got to sit here and
see the
very best of human beings i got to see
the very worst
i got to see what i would do if somebody
had a gun to my head
i got all these things out of the way in
one day that most people go through
their whole life
wondering what they would do
you know i got that out at 21.
what do i have to worry about going into
the next house
you know what i mean i got my ass beat
all of it you're not gonna beat my ass
worse than that so i don't have to worry
about it
you know the most dangerous guy in the
room is the guy that doesn't care to
lose
and i can tell you i don't care lose
you know and that's that's my kryptonite
that's like my power or whatever right
like that's my
and i'm so fortunate to have gotten that
out of the way at 21 years old because
it's allowed me to go
live the life that i've lived right i
get to
man i jump out of airplanes i fly
airplanes i fly helicopters i
i do it and it's like i get to do it
because
and i get to go talk to people about
what it's like i get to go tell people
it's all good you can do this right and
so it's kind of a
it's good it's a good thing
so where does like um i know a while ago
you know you had like anxiety
yeah what even is that what does that
feel like what happens
where does it come from what do you know
about it so i didn't even know
i didn't even know what i didn't even
know i had anxiety
i guess like you just kind of get used
to feeling this way
and i
it got so bad like after i moved to
alaska when the drinking stopped
that like i would i would wake up
throwing up
i would grind my teeth so hard like my
teeth on the back are caps
and like i would i have veneers and i
would knock my teeth off with veneers
like i'd knock them off by grinding my
teeth
um i mean i'd wake up and i'd be
throwing up i would be
sweating in bed crying my eyes out like
just
can't sit down can't like i would try to
run it off i can't run it off can't lay
down like
it just it was like i'm like what's
wrong with me you know i mean what is
wrong
i don't even know what's going on and uh
and then i find out that this is just an
anxiety attack
and um
you know i just i started dealing with
it i had a real bad anxiety attack
but i didn't want to go like i didn't
want to go to the hospital because like
the va gave me the option of the va gave
me an option of um
i call them up okay i call them up and
i'm like hey i need to
like i just need to see somebody and
they're like what do you have a case
manager
i said i don't like i i live in alaska i
don't
and they're like okay now i'm a medal of
honor recipient
um i mean i've got pretty high status in
the va
uh like as far as the statuses they have
right like they have these little levels
or whatever i imagine
it's got to be pretty high up there yeah
so like i asked them
um i'm like i just need to see somebody
like maybe give me like some blood
pressure medicine or something to help
me get this just get through this i just
need to get something to get through it
i don't want any
like i'm not asking for xanax's or
whatever right
and they go well if you don't have a
case manager then we'll have to get you
one of those and then after you get and
seen with the case managers then what
we'll do is
that case manager will get you a doctor
and then after you meet with a doctor
then they'll get you to a psychiatrist
and then you'll be able to get some help
for it
i said well how long is that going to be
probably four to six weeks
and i said i don't have four to six
weeks
and she the the woman on the phone
she said well you can always come check
your in yourself into the psych ward
and i was like
i don't need that there's no way these
are my options
and um so i called i called one of my
buddies and he knew a doctor
and you know the doctor was like they
gave me like some blood pressure
medicine that usually some people take
for anxiety
started taking it and then fortunately
they sent me this thing called the alpha
stem
and um it clips on your ears and uh
when they sent it to me i wouldn't even
open it i got i was so mad that somebody
sent this to me because i was like you
really think
you really this is what you think my
level of anxiety is you think it's a
joke
i'm picturing the thing that um uh
the time travel machine that kit puts on
his head
in napoleon dynamite something like that
so finally one day
i'm sitting there and i've got anxiety
and um and it's like it feels like your
chest is just like
like something sitting on your chest
does it come from like thoughts
no i don't know like is it a physical
thing is it a mental thing physical
to fit like it's all physical like
you'll feel like you're having a heart
attack
um and you you could be watching the
freaking cartoons with your kids
i mean i could be just sitting in my
truck sit in your truck nothing
just playing and all of a sudden you
feel this yeah you can i can i can feel
it coming
is it the same as a panic attack same
thing
but do you feel like you're like worried
about something consciously
or i think it lives in your subconscious
mm-hmm you know like you can't no i mean
i would be
i mean i would be fine and then like it
just all of a sudden hits
and it's like it's like oh gosh like you
can feel it coming and you just
how do i get rid of this and it's i
think it's a subconscious piece right
like
um that's why like it comes out mostly
when i'm sleeping
because i can't consciously control what
i'm thinking about and when i go to
sleep
whatever in your brain needs to come out
is coming out
are you dreaming are you having
nightmares yeah
and the nightmares like trigger this and
usually
when the cure for it because you said
the
case advisor would send you to a doctor
the doctor would send you to a
psychiatrist yeah
so ultimately is that what they're
looking to do to you is give you some
kind of
psychiatric medicine you know xanax's
clottipine
um and these are things that like mellow
you out
yeah or something allegedly they'll
zombie you and get you
get you addicted to them yeah they'll
zombie you because they're gonna numb
the pain they're going to numb the
thoughts
that are that are causing this stuff
yeah yeah and
yeah i mean it's just it's like you get
on that it's a slope right
it's a slope of of
you know well after you start taking
that then you know you start getting
depressed right because i mean
imagine you know and that was always my
problem like if i took if i took
clothing
or anything like that well you have a
hangover the next day
and then i didn't feel like working out
so then i don't feel like working out so
then it's like you just it's like a
depression
it's like this slope of just right then
you know when you when you get depressed
and you start you know you can't work
out or you don't feel your normal self
then you're like well i'm broken and
it's just like this downward slope of
just
it's like hey you know what like i don't
i'm not scared to look at it
i'm not scared to look my demons in the
eyes
um but like when it turns into something
like
mentally i can deal with it it's when it
starts coming out physically
as it starts is it starts getting you
right
so so back to the earlobe freaking
machine so
so the alpha stem um i finally put it on
and it would like melt it away it would
like
melt it away um so you start feeling it
go hook it up i'd hook it up 20 minutes
at night before i went to bed
i'd sleep better yeah it was awesome and
then um
and then i met this i met this person
um she worked with
the guys out at fort bragg um
i met her one and she's like hey you
need to try this
it's called a stella ganglion block
actually a seal sean mulvaney dr
mulvaney
i'm like come on everybody's promised me
the world with this stuff
she's like go do it sgb sgb
and um so i fly out i was i was
i was at rock bottom again like just it
was just you're just just frustrating
that i can't operate
how often are you having these anxiety
attacks twice a week
and they're freaking crippling i'm
talking about throwing up in the floor
like i'm talking about how long they
last for um
an hour 45 minutes you have no idea when
they're gonna hit
no and there's no going back to sleep
after them
right like there's no yeah um and i'll
never forget my daughter
my daughter looked at me one time we
were actually on the road
me and her traveling and uh so like i
would be scared like i never liked the
kids to sleep in the bed with me because
i never wanted my daughters to see me
like that
and um and there were there were a lot
of nights that i would sleep in my car
in the best buy parking lot
um probably about three years ago four
years ago three years ago
i would sleep in the best by parking lot
because i didn't want anybody to see me
see me like that if i felt like i was
getting anxiety and
uh and are you still married at this
time yeah
and um is there any like how's that
going
it's just like you guys are just trying
to figure it out yeah it is what it is
she can't i mean she doesn't you know
she's look
we got three kids and and you know you
know she's watching
i mean how could you be married to
somebody like that how could you be
married to somebody who
you know you look at and and like you
don't understand their anxiety
so like you're kind of like what's wrong
with this person you know what i mean
like this guy's just this weak
you know what i mean it's like it's not
a it's not something it's hard to
understand you know
and um and i'll never forget like me and
sailor were traveling we were actually
at a marine base
and i'd been speaking to a bunch of
marines and she was with me
and she was having to sleep in the bed
with me at you know on on the road
and i will that night i woke up and i
was i was throwing up and i was sitting
on the side's bed crying
and like my i knocked two of my teeth
off my and they came
off and like she uh i honestly forgot
she was in the bed
and um man she got up and like
she like she like patted me on the back
and she said uh
uh it's okay daddy like i know you're a
good daddy
and uh man it was
that was that was a tough one right you
know like it was just
uh and so i uh
then i was like i gotta do something
different you know like i was getting
the stella ganglion blocks
quite a bit so you i cut you off or
whatever but so how was that first one
that you went and got
the needle went in so i was laying on
this hot this bed so that the process is
that they stick a needle into some part
of your
neck brain so your neck so like they do
it under ultrasound
and like they stick this needle on and
it like
it's a block um and and it goes on your
it goes on one of your nerves and um
it's like a reset
and man as soon as before the needle was
even out
i remember i was looking at i was like
literally looking at the ceiling
and i didn't want anybody to talk
because
i got i couldn't believe that that i
could feel this way
like it was like the world the weight of
the world was off my shoulders like the
anxiety was gone like it was
like i didn't know you could feel like
that and i was just
the next morning like i was taking a
shower and i was i caught myself like
laughing and singing in the shower and i
was like this is like amazing
and so i did that and that worked for a
while
what's it blocking so i guess what it
does
is you have you have um this is how i
was explained to me was you have your
automated um basically like
where you automatically do things like
breathing things you don't have to think
about blinking
and then you have your um where you have
to
like your manual side of your your
nervous system right like we're okay i
want to pick this cup up i have to think
about that and do it
so fight or flight is supposed to be i
recognize you as a threat
you're a threat now so i recognize that
now i go into fight or flight
and what happens is when we've been in
in that mode for so long
your mind just starts to adapt and it
puts it over into the automated side
and so that's where you get these guys
who are
automatically back in that fight or
flight um
they automatically go back there because
their brain is shoved in that system
so so you're kind of like a imagine with
your
your cell phone if it's running wrong or
an app's running wrong what do you do
you reboot her down yeah well that's
what this block does is it doesn't
really shut it down but it kind of helps
you reboot your system
and that's dr mulvaney was one of the
first guys to ever give this for ptsd
and what he did was
he went he was i guess he was at this
clinic
and he was seeing all these symptoms
that
pregnant women were having
when they were when they were going
through pregnancies and they were giving
this i guess it for some piece of it
and he's like well this is kind of these
symptoms are kind of
let me try it for this and like it's
been
huge i've saved so i mean saving lives
like
a lot of a lot of the guys get it you
know and um
it helped me for a long time yeah i got
i got some people that have been
reaching out to me to talk about it and
maybe have some of the
experts on here to kind of explain it so
more people can understand it and yeah
and actually when they approached me i
said well i got a friend that had it and
i actually asked you and i said hey did
you get that thing you said yep and i
said how was it you said it's freaking
awesome
awesome so that kind of opened my mind
up and said all right you know if i just
can help spread the word on this then
let's do it
yeah and you know like all these things
are like let me say this like
like the the alpha stem it was it was
great
worked great right uh the stella
ganglion block like all these things
they work um it's just a matter of how
long they work right
like the alpha stem i'd have to use it
pretty much every day right
this stellar ganglion block i mean
sometimes i would go six months without
getting one
sometimes i'd have to go three months
you know it just it's about the
longevity
of how long they worked you know and and
honestly none of it's going to fix it
you have to fix it yourself like these
are all
i call them uh they're kind of like
flash bangs
um they're they're the flash bangs of
life it's gonna it's the
you're gonna throw that flashbang in
there and it's gonna give you some time
to get on the offense
in where they're on the defense right so
you better make
you better fix it of whatever is causing
it
you better get in there and start doing
work as soon as
as soon as it as soon as you get it
right it's not a you're not going to sit
here and take it
and and they're you know not have to go
home and work on your life
and work on the way you think about
things you know you got work to do
so yeah so what's that work look like
because when you i know what i do when i
throw a
flashbang in the room i know what to do
next i know what that work is
what's the work when that you're talking
about uh i mean look
some people want to go do some
counseling right go into talking to
people
what i say when people go to counseling
i say uh i tell people
if you don't have goals don't go to
counseling
like don't go into counseling and think
that it's gonna be somebody else fixing
it for you
that's kind of like calling up a trainer
and thinking that you you know you can
go the best gym you can have the best
trainer and the best nutritionist but
you still got to put in the work you
still got to eat the right food and you
still got to show up and do it right
and it's kind of the same thing with
counselors um
know what you want changed you know
really
look at a take a hard look in the mirror
and and
it starts with accountability and like a
lot of people want to avoid
accountability because as soon as you
recognize as soon as you say and look in
the mirror and say hey i'm fat
well then you've made a conscious choice
not to do something about it
and um so for me like
i know that i have to get like usually i
look in the mirror and i start seeing
who i'm surrounded
by like when i start going down that
road the first thing i look at
where am i spending my time um
and that usually tells me the most of it
right so i'll back off of that
and then um and then i just start
i start you know if i need to go to
counseling if i want to talk to people
i'll talk to people but most time for me
like
i want to talk to i'll call you or i'll
call
i call people and they don't even know
why i'm calling them but i'll call them
i'll call them just to get it out
whenever your freaking name pops up
on my phone i'm like here we go i'm like
do i have an hour
yes i do we're ready to rock
[Music]
sometimes i get off the phone with you i
was sitting on my front porch talking to
you one day
i got a phone i called you for like five
minutes and we were on the phone for an
hour
and i got off the phone and i'm like i
promise you i walk back and i'm like i
don't even know why this guy answers the
phone for me
i remember one time we were talking and
when i got off
my wife was like who was that
i was like it was dakota she goes i have
never heard you laugh
so freaking hard for so long i
i one time i remember i was in my
kitchen
and i had tears literally tears were
coming out of my eyes
i was laughing so freaking hard at what
you were telling me
and uh man and that's happened a few
times it's happened a few times
i mean oh yeah so
yeah i i i know when i see that when i
see dakota pop up on my phone i'm like
all right
yeah i should freaking record those
things and i could record them for
counseling i could record them for
podcasts or i could
record them for comic freaking relief
yeah you know cause like you you you
don't help it though
like let me say this you you are like
the fuel of it
because because i'll say something
and you'll say like a few little words
just like you know like
i'll be coming down and he'll just like
say something else engage and it's like
here we go again
no i remember one time you called me too
and you were like man you were ready to
go
hot oh i was and i was like all right
man
and actually i remember what i said i
said okay let's think about this
strategically
let's think about this strategically
what if you execute what you're talking
about execute
i said i said where are you gonna be in
six months
where you're gonna be in three years
we're gonna be five years like that was
pretty much all i had to say
oh oh yeah i remember i remember that
conversation
yeah choco all jack told me was
and he didn't say not to do it i
understand this he didn't say
not to do it he uh he said hey
he said if you're gonna do it um
like only do it if it's worth losing
everything that's exactly what he told
me
and uh that's a big statement
that's what i'm left with and i was
walking around lowe's and i was like
yeah yeah i don't think we're there yet
all right so
he's working around like what is the
hard work
we're not talking about we're not
talking about that but we will see
it was not legal in no way
it was the no way but i already thought
he had a freaking course of action brief
for me he's called me like i was a
freaking
battlefield commander he's like hey boss
i got a corpse of action i want to run
by you see if i can get mission execute
on this thing
i'm like okay go ahead i'm all ears bro
what you got
seven minutes later you know he's
running through timelines
execution checklist i'm like okay you
already had the cover-up story ready to
go you know
but like that to me is like like that
like but you know what like but i know
who to call right
like i know in that situation i'm not
gonna call some idiot
you know what i mean because next thing
you know they're like we're gonna
meet you let's do it right like i i know
i know like i'm so fortunate i got i've
got all like i've got quite a few
just people that i just look up to so
much and i trust
i trust like like you like if you tell
me something
like i i know i know it's what you would
do
and so i trust that right like i know
it's exactly what you believe in what
you would do
and so like that's why that's why i
would call you with something like that
or i would call you
and that's for me that's that's my
that's how i fix myself you know what i
mean yeah no
it's it's uh believe it or not if you
have people around you
that can are are on the same wavelength
as you
it's a method of actually detaching from
the situation because you're all wrapped
up in it right you're with the emotions
and all this stuff you're all wrapped
up and i'm not just saying you but any
human echo could be all wrapped up in
some emotional thing
and call me up and be like hey this
what's going on this is what i want to
do
because we're bros i i'm thinking in
your best interest i'm thinking in your
best interest
so i'm but i'm not wrapped up in it so i
can say hey man
let's think through what you want to do
right now let's see what the long term
let's do the long term in that why like
in fights
i mean their coaches are in the coaches
the coach is in the corner right
like the coach isn't out there
necessarily
you know engaging or necessarily having
to put in the physical piece of it
but the coaches make sure the guy
doesn't get too emotional making sure to
stay stick to the plan
exactly and and that's why it's so
important in life
you know like even back when
all this media stuff used to go on and i
would get hammered
like i have a few people who are very
the
wanted some of the best in the media
world and
i'll back up and call them and you know
what i make a rule i make a rule that as
soon as i pick up the phone
like i'm not calling you for advice like
when i call you about that
like if you say don't don't do this or
hey do this
why listen to that because i picked up
the phone and i called and asked it
like i'm not gonna sit here and ask you
and then go do something stupid because
like
why would i even waste your time you
know and and that's i think that's so
important to have those people in your
life
um to be that logic side when you get
into the emotional side too much
you know for sure all right so
we're getting the the stella ganglion
block
and that's sort of giving you the
opportunity
to to to work some of these things out
you know the weird thing is i was
thinking about so one of the things that
i know for a fact right
so you know um for me
i'll i'll go and talk to a company or
i'll go and talk to people
or i'll talk on this podcast about the
worst days of my life right when i lost
guys
and it's i believe
it's helpful because i've like okay i've
talked about i've written this down i've
explained what the situation is even
even you know um giving like
eulogies for my friends at their
at their uh memorial services like you
have to kind of think
through things and you have to process
them and then you write down and then
you
like even that for me it sucks and it's
freaking horrible
but at the same time i know that it it
allows me to sort of
gather together my thoughts and put them
in some kind of perspective and when you
write something down
you're actually detaching from it you're
actually detaching from it
you're it's on the paper it's it's it's
actually on the paper
and then when you talk to some people
about it it's like oh you get to see
their perspective
they get to give you some of their
perspective about it and so it's a way
of
um uh i i guess
just working through the problem like
it's like almost like stretching your
when you're sore you know you stretch
out right it's almost like that hey i'm
gonna get some blood back in there i'm
gonna think through this
and the difference for you like in those
early days is
people are just putting their
perspective on you it's like just
layering it on you all the time yeah and
like let me ask you this so like
when you like what how old like
where were you at in your life like when
you lost your guys
five okay were you married yes okay so
like
so like check so like how old are you
right now
i'm 32. yeah so so my
my thing is is right is like
what would have happened if
you know you you you you had
that had happened 10 years before for
sure you know you know what i mean so
like i think that's what's
i think that's where you like that
that's that's that's what's awesome
about
is like you're kind of like for just for
me
i'll talk about for me like you're the
um
you're you're the uh well i can like
you're the
you're the better side of this like i
can like you you give hope to a guy like
me
that man i'm i i can get there i can i
can i can be okay
like this ain't this ain't like the
realities that are in my mind sometimes
like i understand like i can look at
somebody and say look no no this isn't
reality it's like i'm not i will figure
this out
if i if i if i hang around people if i
hang around jocko
and i take that and i take that
mentorship i can be that someday i can
get there someday
i can literally look at it's not an idea
your reality
and for a guy like me that's reality and
i think that's
but but on the backside of it you're not
giving me you're not giving me advice
the guys if i talk to my buddies like
i'm taking advice from a guy who's seen
it
at 23 21 my themselves right
you got to see it from a perspective at
an older age with a different life
100 percent my my whole in fact i
my whole experience of like being in
combat was
the most the most gentle like
rot like the first operations i did were
like no there was like nothing like cool
we're going outside the wall it was like
this really nice kind of ramp slow ramp
it wasn't just like oh
welcome to combat you know everything's
freaking crazy
so i you know even even like the the
just the nervousness about of being like
oh this is real
like that was i i was very lucky yeah
i got that out of my system the first
five ops i went on and nothing happened
right i was like okay cool i kind of got
this right and then it was just a slow
kind of ramp from there
and and yes i was old
i mean i can't believe i was three years
older than you are right freaking now
that's pretty crazy and i'd spent my
whole life in the military
and that's what you know so that yeah i
was a huge
i was very very lucky in the way things
unfolded
and when things if they got when they
got
not good for you you had a person in
your life that you trusted with
everything
that you knew if you were starting to
get off the path
you knew you could look at her and you
could have a good gauge you had a
you had a very good gauge of the man
that
that you were yeah and i think more than
um in my own mind i realized
that i needed to and i'll tell you what
i talked about this with jp when jp was
on here
and um and so
when when mikey got killed we were
sending him home and he was you so we're
going into like a conex box to like
say goodbye to him one at a time and
like i walk so basically you can walk in
the connex box you see mike you know
freaking give him a kiss and and and say
goodbye
and then turn around and walk back out
and um i remember
just looking at at jp and because jp was
like right ahead of me walking in
and as he's walking back out like i see
jp and jp was
22 or 23 years old
and this was his bro and i look at his
face and he
is just [ __ ] just
absolute torment in his face and i said
to myself like
hey jocko you better keep your [ __ ]
together right now
because like you said earlier like it's
like a breaking point
and people if one person breaks and i'm
the guy that's
allegedly in charge and if i break down
right now man
it's gonna be it's gonna be a nightmare
and i remember seeing him he turned
around he looked at me in the eyes and
his
face was just tormented and and jp such
a passionate guy and he's so emotional
and and and he was young you know and i
just remember
i said i better you got to keep your
[ __ ] together right now
because they cuz you know they they need
you
right they need you to act like a
[ __ ] man right now
and that's what i had to do and i kind
of felt like you know with
with my wife with my family it's the
same type of thing like hey you gotta
hold the line like you gotta you gotta
do this
and and look my wife's a freaking badass
you know
she's the one that was i you know i
didn't i didn't go to mikey's funeral
i was still in iraq i didn't go to
mark's funeral i was still in iraq like
this is
this is this is my wife going to those
things you know
so and she's by the way she's got three
kids yeah you know she's getting a
babysitter so she can go to my friend's
funerals
so i'm not trying to sit here and say
like oh i had to be
all strong she had to be strong
but that's what um i i guess
to your point i was older
i had a little bit more life experience
and you know as you get older you're
you're more able to handle things and
put them in perspective yeah i mean so
like
at 33 that would be 12 years
older than what i was when it happened
to me
you know and i'm by no means i'm not i'm
not saying
that it's either way or the other i'm
just saying that like
the world's a little bit different then
right and and and you know like
the maturity levels of how i handled a
lot of it is not
the right way you know what i mean like
was drinking and going out and
and you know punching people in the face
like you know and
in the new book we we have coming out
right like i talk about like
you know just i mean man i was evil
like i want to tell you like i came back
and
i mean i was mean i was mean
and the problem was is like when you
take mean
and you take a guy who doesn't care and
a guy who felt like he's already lost
everything
like that is a dangerous dude like i
would
it was nasty i would say stuff like i
hurt my family
i mean i would say do stuff and it's
just you know and and
i'm not saying like i just didn't handle
it right and i didn't have anybody there
to to hold the line with me you know
like
i mean everybody i i mean my whole team
was gone like everybody like my
the the leaders on my team were gone and
um
yeah i mean it and you know do i regret
i regret a ton of it
and maybe if i had dealt with it better
and maybe i had
you know you just never know right and
um but yeah it's just
it's different it's different you know
this brings me back to something you
were talking about earlier
and i just want to so you're talking
earlier about like having a mentor and
having people
and i i just want to say like
you know if you're in a position where
you can help somebody out that maybe
you've already been through the haunted
house and you can give them a heads up
and i think people when they hear uh
being a mentor this isn't like this has
to be some official thing
like hello dakota would you like me to
mentor you this is not what i'm talking
about
but just being being someone that can
indirectly say hey man how's it going
like hey
what are you doing with that hey what do
you what do you think's gonna happen
next
just those kind of comments to be a
mentor you don't have to sign up
and you don't have to you don't have to
freaking go through a course
you know there's no eight week what
would you what was your baby care course
goal there's no course
there's no course for how to handle a 22
year old or whatever it doesn't exist
but just giving sharing your experience
and the other thing is you don't have to
be perfect
i'm damn far from i'm not even i'm not
in the same ballpark
right you don't have to be perfect to be
able to say hey listen
dakota when this happened to me
here's what i did here's the actual
mistakes that i made yeah
right there here's the things that i
freaking completely screwed up
watch out for these things so it's not
hey dakota
here's what i'm doing and i was perfect
no not even close
so maybe you might be thinking listen
this like well oh
uh uh you know i'm not good enough to be
someone's mentor [ __ ]
or maybe you think i don't want to be
be someone's friend build a relationship
with them and show them the freaking
path through the haunted house tell them
what they can expect even if you screwed
it up it's better than
it's better than uh than letting them
just you know get
get in a bad situation but don't try to
mentor them on something you have not
gone through
don't say it up front that's got to be
your disclosure
yeah of you know and
and like i'm so fortunate because like
i mean i'm surrounded by people i don't
deserve like i've got i
i i mean i i'm just so fortunate to have
just great people i can pick up the
phone and call it
hey what do you think about this right
and you know
i tell you the one thing that i cut out
whenever i start going you know when i
tell you i have to do that
self-reflection and look around
the people who are feeding into my
[ __ ] are the people that have to go
like the people who hype me up on my
[ __ ] like when i call up and i'm
like hey
yeah what do you think about this oh you
know like no that's [ __ ] or whatever
right like that's the first people that
have to go
um i don't i don't need a cheerleading
squad
you know i need people who are going to
look at me like tim kennedy
like tim kennedy looking at me and
saying like you know i i'll never forget
when
we were working out one time and um
i said something he could tell i was
down i was going through my divorce and
stuff
and i looked at him and i said man i
made like an offhanded comment like gosh
i'm i'm fat
and he like tim stopped what he was
doing and he looked at me and he said
hey check it out
he said you when people hear your name
they look at you as a warrior when you
walk on stage they expect a warrior when
you talk they expect a warrior
when you wake up in the morning they
expect a warrior so you know what you
need to do you need to look in the
mirror you need to start acting like one
and that was it turn around went back to
work out right but that's what i need
right like was that like a kick to me
a hundred percent but like i don't need
people
to feed into to my [ __ ] i need
people who are gonna hold me accountable
to standards that i can't even hold
myself to to to know what i can be
and hold me to that standard no hold the
line
when i don't even see it myself
yeah no doubt and tim kennedy is one of
those coming at you
coming at you live man when he calls me
it's always gonna like
he calls me for like reasons he's like
hey this is what's going on he's like
ready to brief me
it's freaking legit he's like hey here's
what's going on i got this this and i'm
like hey roger that
let me think about this okay here's a
move you know or whatever
here's a deal like like if i called tim
kennedy up and i said hey man
um like if he thought i was feeling
sorry for myself i was like hey man
i think i'm just gonna end it today like
i honestly think that tim would be like
oh
hey just make sure you leave all your
cool like out hey can i have your two
guns
like he's not gonna play the simple like
if if i needed something though
like the dude would be like like hey i
killed this guy all right
well i'll bring the shovel you know what
i mean like
but i know these guys are like that yeah
and
and that's why i'm so fortunate because
i got that circle right like that circle
is everything
yeah and i guess what i'm saying is
that's awesome and everybody that's
listening you can actually
be part of that circle for somebody else
100 and if you do that man
you you make such a huge impact in
people's lives
by doing that
how long were was the stellate ganglion
block
like of the deal are you still getting
that
i don't like i um
i probably did it up until 2020. um
and then my buddy
um i was struggling real bad like i was
it just i don't know i was just still i
was still struggling with it right
and um he's like
you gotta you're going to mexico and i
was like
for what he said don't worry about it
you're going to mexico i he said
quite a few veterans are going down
there
guys i trusted he named off a few people
that i trusted had gone to this
and i said all right and so i booked a
trip
and flew into san diego and so i was
going
down to do it's a therapy
uh with ibogaine and five and meow dmt
and something that i
was the furthest thing that i could
you could ever get me to be around i was
like
this is complete [ __ ] and honestly i
was gonna go and i told the doctor when
i got there i said hey i'm coming to
this
just so i can walk away from this and
tell people
that this is all this is all [ __ ]
and i told him that i said as soon as
this doesn't work i'm gonna go on every
podcast i can
and i'm gonna tell everybody that this
is all this is all
so what were you going for what was it
it's called eyeball game okay
and uh it comes from a room what was the
other thing that you said five meow it
comes from a toad
dmt so this is when mike tyson and uh
and joe rogan are talking about riding
the toad this is what they're talking
about
you rode the toad yeah um so i went down
there and i was in a bad
like i was still like my anxiety just
you know and i
and and for me like the only thing that
i like when i look back at it
whatever what what always got me to the
point of where i'm like i don't know if
i'm gonna wake up tomorrow
was anxiety from like the best way to
describe it for you is
imagine when you're under water and you
you can't breathe you should know very
well i do
what will you do to get to the top to
get a breath
whatever it takes right and that's what
anxiety is
like if you can't get rid of it
you'll get to the point to where you're
like if i have to end it
for anxiety to get rid of this feeling i
will do that
and that was the part that was the only
thing that got me there
and so i went down there um
the other guy i'm talking about i won't
mention his name but he was struggling
too and let me tell you something he's
one of the hardest dudes i know
my team leader you know and this was
about a year after my team leader
who was a marine sniper took me through
got me to become marine sniper went to
iraq with him deployed with him then he
went over it got out of the marine corps
and said forget it i'm going to go be a
navy seal became a navy seal
um deployed with the navy seals the team
out in
hawaii and then uh
one day he just said i'm done and put it
put it put his gun in his mouth and
killed himself
uh my another hard guy i know and so
you know when people call these guys
cowards um
they're not cowards uh
they're not cowards these are some of
the hardest man that have ever walked to
face the planet
and that's why you know i you have to
take it serious and uh
so anyways this guy he went down there i
get down there
and uh you have to sound like paperwork
that says
you may experience that you're dying
i mean it's one of the scariest things
i've ever done and after you take it
there's no
you write it too there's no offering
and so i took this i so you go there and
it was like
you didn't eat all day on a friday i
took the ibogaine at 8 00 p.m on friday
and now you're talking about you
they were like doing this sage stuff
like hippie stuff and i'm like you guys
are hippies like i don't i don't need
any of that
like i i'm nothing against hippies but
i'm just not one right
i don't know i can't get into this you
know
waving this stuff around or whatever and
um
believe in whatever you want again but
like i couldn't i couldn't get in the
mood
and so i'm like i take it and uh
you have to write down your intentions
on this piece of paper
and i just wrote that um
i just wanted for some relief i wanted
some
i just wanted some relief whatever
so you go up you lay down in this room
you lay on this
the bed this bed's on the floor and uh
you put these blindfolds over and i
didn't feel anything for a minute
wait when you take it what is that like
a drink it's like like
pill it's measured out so you take it
water you know i
in you and i talked a little bit before
you came out here and and
i i knew about some of these things that
you were trying and
i don't know about these things yeah and
one of my friends tim ferriss is like
just to to to say like when you're like
oh this hippie stuff
that's kind of the way i think too right
and
and i like want to understand it better
because
i know it help you look even even rogan
he told me he's like i think it will
help i think it will help
dakota yeah and you and i went back and
forth i was like hey man
i'm gonna ask joe and i said hey joe
what do you think and at that point he'd
met you and he you've been on his
podcast
and he was like that was actually you
actually texted me
i did you were like hey this is what i'm
coming to san diego for what do you
think i was like dude i don't freaking
know
let me ask rogan so i asked him and of
course what does he say
no but he but he wasn't i mean as much
as rogan is is
understands the stuff and he's for it he
was also like
he laid out reasons yeah i'll text him
and ask him a question about something
and he'll be like no don't no that is
not gonna help if you're trying it for
this
he's like nope that won't help you so so
that's one part of it like rogan has
that level of understanding and then on
the other side
uh tim ferriss is like trying to get
this stuff
approved medically and trying to get
support there and so i just asked him to
give me a rundown of like hey
what is all this stuff you know what
it's not just hippie stuff and he's like
no it's not just hippie stuff and
here's what it isn't and like he said i
begin because he he was kind of talking
me through this
ibogaines from some shrub in africa
and and he said it's like the most
powerful the most powerful there is
right he said a lot of seals do it
because seals are like
you know all right what i'm going hard
yeah what do you got
and so so that's what iba game is
ibogaine is it's a
a lot of times they use it for opiate
addiction so yeah
like it's so it's so hardcore
that they put these people on it for
opioid addiction and it kicks their ass
to where they don't do opioids again
all right so back to your story so you
so you take the thing
they're waving they're waving hippy
stuff like they're waving no offenses
no no offense no i mean i just i
couldn't
and i like they laughed at me the whole
time right they're like
i'm like yeah whatever i can't get are
these are these americans that are down
there
are they so there was like uh yeah all
of them were except for two
okay um and uh
so we're we're there in this house and
um and then there's a bunch of
there's a bunch of seals there as like
that
are making sure we nothing nobody comes
in
that are there to help you um
if you need something but like all i'm
gonna tell you all i'm gonna say is like
i was surrounded by seals
um and so that tells me like hey like
seals are no [ __ ] like you know what
i mean like
and that's yeah so i took it
and um all of a sudden like
it's i feel it's starting to come like
it it's like
it was like the spinning and um
and you were just like it was like all
right it's like i was watching my life
on a tv screen
and uh i didn't see anything from war
and uh i was walking through this town
and everything looked gloomy
and uh i i i'll never forget i went into
this one room
and i went in this room and i i seen
like all these people like this huge
crowd
and uh but i felt
like just disappointment and um
and i got i did my typical me of wanting
to fix it like
what did i do wrong like how can i fix
this and i kept running up to all of
them
and then it would be like flashing of
people that i knew
and people that like
i knew i hadn't done anything to but
just did it for manipulation
and like they were just flashing on and
on
and finally i'm just like well what did
i do wrong and like i just remember
feeling this
like this feeling of just defeat and i
was in there for probably four hours
and then i came out and as i was walking
down the town
like i would look at every little gauge
and it would be
like uh the gauge would instead like it
would fill up and instead of being at
full
it would say finished and it would be
like this far from finished and i never
finished anything
and then i would see this beautiful ball
of light and i would go to it and it
would be my two daughters playing
and this went on until
3 p.m on saturday afternoon
and i'll never forget there was at one
point of it
i uh
like i was just like i just felt like i
was such
a just trash that i was finally just
like
i just i don't care anymore like my ego
it took my ego and just smashed it and
it's like
i don't care what anybody thinks i don't
care
i know i wake up and i i'm the best man
i know i give my best i'm not perfect i
know that i know that i don't come off
and say the right things
but i know what my intent is i know
there's you couldn't look at me and make
me question my intent like you can
definitely question my delivery you can
criticize
how i come off or how i do this or but
my intent is there
and my intent is good and i'll never
forget
like that it broke everything it's like
got to the point where i didn't care
anymore and like i'll never forget i was
laying there and i was like
just i'd like if this is how i die this
is how i die
and um i just didn't care anymore i
didn't care what my mom thought of me
i didn't care what you know all these
people that i had
i had invested in and i had gave them
these titles
which when you give somebody titles you
give them authority
i didn't care anymore you're not going
to tell me
what my intent is
and so i come out of it i was so pissed
off
when i came out of it like i literally
looked at the doctor and i said this is
what you brought me here for
i said i called up the guy who sent me
there who's a close friend
i said this is 100 [ __ ] like i was
so down
like out because my biggest fear was
opening pandora's box
and um he's like wait till the next day
so the next day you do this this 5mu dmt
and um i'll never forget like i i i
wanted to make sure i seen the world
the same so i'm looking out this window
in mexico and we're looking out we're
right by the ocean and i look out and
all i can see is
all i can think in my head is man this
place is a [ __ ] that's all i could
think
i go down and do this dmt and i i lay
down and as soon as you go like it's
almost like it
it was like feet first like i was like
gone like to a tube
right and um
and it feels real or do you know that
you're like
you know you're tripping you don't see
anything no you you know
i mean you know it's it's not like it's
a physical thing like when you drink you
physically feel drunk
it's like your soul like it's it's not a
it's not a physical reaction it's like
your soul
and i was
it was gone and like you can't see
anything it was pure white it was the
most beautiful white
that i've ever seen in my life it was
there's no
there's no word in the english
dictionary to ever describe how
beautiful the white was
and all i could feel was love
like i felt good i felt like you could
feel what good is
like if you took how i feel when my
daughters
give me a hug or that that unconditional
love
like that's what the whole place felt
like it was like the perfect temperature
i didn't think about anything else
and all i heard were my teammates say
that it was all right
and um yeah
it was like it was like everything bad
was gone it was like i got
like a reset in my life and uh
when i came back two i set up and i just
like i started crying and i looked at
these these two women who were there
these two nurses
and i just couldn't believe that like
there were such
they were like i had to like i'm in
mexico and there's two people who
genuinely care about me
and uh i care about me enough to
to help me through this and i looked out
the window and i was like gosh this is
the most beautiful place i've ever been
and i didn't have any anxiety after that
i went back home the stuff that like
would send me over the edge
man i was just happy to be alive i was
just i woke up every like i
still i mean still still i get up
and do i have bad days yeah but
but like i'm just happy to be here
you know like
like i you know i i just it changed my
whole life
like i i came back and my anxiety was
i mean i get normal there is normal
anxiety
but like that those anxiety attacks
i haven't had one since
how long has it been it'll be two years
this november
you know the thing that you said about
intent is something that i
i i talk about a lot from a from a
leadership
perspective and that bleeds over into
life because i think if you're doing the
right things for the right reasons if
your intent is good
you're gonna be okay right if you're not
trying to screw somebody over if you're
not trying to maneuver if you're not
trying to
you know sneak one by somebody if you're
not trying to look out for your own
agenda like the military it's a classic
example you get an officer
or a senior enlisted leader that what
their intent is to get themselves
promoted or what their intent is to get
themselves a freaking
award or credit or accolades if that's
what their intent is everybody can see
it
and it doesn't work out good for them in
the end
if their intent is good that they want
to get the mission done that they want
to take care of their team that they
wanna that they're putting themselves
below their team and lifting their team
up like that intent is
what what makes a good leader what makes
a good person
and i think when people have bad intent
it eats them apart it eats them up
and they can they can have bad intent
you can cover it up you can try and
drown it out you can pretend that it's
not there but it's there
and and what i tell people is like
intent you can smell people's intent
and the worst part about it is you can
smell your own intent
you can and if you have bad intent you
have to sit in that rot and
stink yourself and it will eat you apart
you can
you can put perfume all over it you can
put deodorant all over it
it's still there and you know it so
that's like a realization that you had
of my intent
is good yeah like
like look your intent
is is your foundation of your house
your priorities are
basically the shell of your house
they can change you can move rooms you
can adjust on it
right um but if your intent
you know if your intent is is
is wrong that house is not going to
stand
you can't keep building on that house
you can't keep adding on to you can't
keep making it better
the foundation is done it's done and the
only difference between
murder and self-defense is intent 100
and nobody can question that
no it it is what it is it's it's black
and white
it is it is an your intent is absolute
and that's ultimately
when you start digging down the root of
this tree
that's ultimately what's going to decide
if you're going to hold up in the bad
times
or not yeah the the thing is and i
i don't know if you i don't know if i
caught exactly what you said but
i've seen people and change their intent
in their life
100 okay so i i i thought you said like
oh you can't change your intent you
can't change your intent of something
that happened in the past
but if you've been running around
looking out for yourself
and stepping on people's backs and
that's the way you roll
you can change that you can actually
begin to act like a good person
yeah but but here's what i'll tell you
is is you can't be both
that is true you cannot you can't
you can't be selfish and selfless
you're either one or the other and there
is no
well i'm selfish at these times but i'm
selfless at these times
no no because then when you're selfless
you're only being selfless when you want
to be selfless and that's selfish
right like there's no being both in this
life like you don't get to
you don't get to skirt the line you're
either all in on one or the other
and it's obvious and there's no
there's no there's no any there's no ex
there's no
excuse for that it is what it is and you
know it and you know it on everything
you do
you ultimately know it is it like a
one-time
thing i just i've done it once and then
you know the only the only thing i'll do
now
is like a like i'll use psilocybin
if i if i start feeling anxiety come
around right like
um i'll i'll just do a dose of
psilocybin okay so psilocybin
is mushroom mushrooms yeah and
and then when you say you feel it coming
is this like
hey tomorrow like i feel like i'm
nervous about tomorrow or is it like
hey i'm starting to feel nervous right
now no i start like
you know like i came home from that
ibogaine experience and like
i got to see the world in a place that
i've never seen it
like i got to see like with a relief
that i had never felt i didn't know that
people could really walk around like
this
and um
uh you know i i mean you gotta take i
grew up in chaos
um i mean the only a lot of times you
know my
my biggest thing is is not like people
talk about being in like
the the dark places why i'm comfortable
there
the problem i have is is being in the
light where there's not dark places
you know i have the problem of being
when there's no chaos you want to talk
about where i'm the best
is is you put me in the most chaotic
environment and it needs to get figured
out
like and the stakes are high well that's
that's where i'm good the problem i'm
trying to learn
is how to be okay when it's not chaotic
and that's what i have to have that's
what i have to work on
how often do you feel like that
anxiety's coming
and you go like like how often do you
feel like oh i i better get a little bit
of
a little bit of psilocybin to help me
get through this
you know once a quarter one like
so i'm just me personally
like i i don't think
like i i don't none of this stuff do i
look at is a recreational type of thing
like i don't i don't think i think if
if you if you're using it as a medicinal
piece as a
not as a medicinal of i'm going to do it
every night before i go to bed
you know what i mean like if you're
using it to
because it's something you need nobody
questions somebody who takes blood
pressure medicine
you know what i mean like so you know
for me about once a quarter
you know and i'll do like
i'll do a big dose like
like like like a six or six or seven
grams
of psilocybin and then like
how i'm good it's like five hours
and then i'm good
so before we wrap up this little section
on uh this is this is
i like i said i talked to tim and and he
just
gave me a bunch of really good
information because
i don't understand this stuff i don't
know about it i've never done it before
and but i've talked to so many of my
friends
that have had that it's helped them so
much you included
that i i want you know i have an open
mind i want to understand it better
um you know a couple of things that he
said actually there's a few things that
he said
number one like because the veteran
community has gone through such
traumatic experiences
that's the main group to to
need this type of treatment the other
one is is survivors
or victims of traumatic assaults whether
that's sexual assaults or physical
assaults but
people that have been through that so
it's but but there's no
federal funding for it so there's no
federal funding for it
which means there's no there's not
enough money it's just people that are
donating
donating money to try and try and help
get
funding for more research um
the thing about specifically he said
about mushrooms is they've been used for
thousands of years right so mushrooms
have been used for thousands of years
um and and he also said and this was
interesting to me like there's no you
don't need you don't want to do more
no he said you do some and you're like
okay i don't want to do more
it's not it's not like heroin or cocaine
where when you do cocaine apparently
because i've never done it but
apparently when you do it you just want
to do more
when you do i had a neighbor that had
gotten out of prison and moved in with
his uncle
and i he was he was out of prison after
seven years and he
um he was on meth and he said the first
he said hey the first time i did crystal
meth
it was the only thing i ever wanted to
do for the rest of my life
yeah so and he went right down that path
and stole from everybody that he knew
and freaking wrecked his life and ended
up in jail
uh but you know what tim was saying is
like there's there's like an
anti-addictive like
um because you can't you don't want to
do it every day
no i mean like i couldn't imagine if you
thought you were going to go out and
party and somebody gave you a thing of
ibogaine
you know what i mean like like like like
i couldn't imagine
if you thought you were gonna go out and
party and you took you know
six to eight grams of psilocybin like
for me personally maybe i'm weak but i i
just i couldn't imagine and like there's
nothing
about it like it's like work
like if i'm taking this like i know i'm
going in to do some work
the um the way he was describing it to
me and he's heard me talk about
detaching you know wrote about
leadership strategy
he's talking about detachment he's like
oh yeah here's what it is he goes
uh mushrooms psilocybin is like it is
your brain can detach and look at what
is going on
and then you can find a solution for it
you just made a face like yes
it's clarity okay i get off like i come
off of it
and i can think clearer than i've ever
been able to think
he he said you know ibogaine definitely
got to be careful
he said there's cardiac risk like you
can have some significant problems from
that
um whereas mushrooms
he said basically i don't think there's
any like reported ods
on mushrooms you would have to do pounds
of it and there's no way you could do
pounds of mushrooms
he also said that
he said look there's a whole warning
thing right there's a whole like
warning thing that you need to watch out
for uh
specifically if you've had schizophrenia
in your family it's like a big red flag
it's probably a no-go they don't
when when they're testing it they don't
test it on people that
that have had those types of uh problems
before but
um
like you said like it's like these these
things are one to two maybe three
sessions and you don't
need it anymore um so some of the other
warnings look there's legal
like there's it's illegal yes it's
illegal it's illegal
so you can't do it you're not allowed to
you're not allowed to do it
um and if you get caught with it you
you'll go to jail you go you go to jail
so
that's that's number one right
the other thing that tim said is like
you've gotta for him he's like if
somebody asked me about it he says
here's the protocol you know a month of
preparation
and the preparation that he's putting on
people is like hey you got to meditate
every day you've got to he's got some
books to read
um you got to do that he said you got to
look at it like
if you're getting knee surgery if you're
an athlete and getting knee surgery what
do you do you go out you research you
find the best doctor
you do the there's prep work to get
ready to have surgery you got to like
work out a certain way and do certain
exercises to get ready
then once you get the surgery done you
got to go into re you got to rehab
and you and it's what you said earlier
like you got to do the work
you got to do the work and like if
you're not willing to put in that work
on the front end
you don't respect it enough to do it you
don't have you don't want to get better
you don't want to use it for the intent
that it needs to be used for right
like all these things i take it very
serious like i don't
let me tell you something like i
i mean it's even hard for me to talk
about like honestly like
just up front like it's hard for me to
even talk about in this room because
it's like this is something that i in
this room a year ago
two years ago would have looked at like
what are you doing
right and it's hard to bring that up
around people that i know and trust
because if they haven't you it's one of
those things if you haven't done it
but then i start thinking to myself why
can i drink alcohol
you know what i mean why why can i do
all these other things that somebody has
allowed me
to do i could go to the va right now and
get prescribed collodopen
i could get xanax's i could be out of my
mind on all
these pharmaceuticals and that's
acceptable
in our society and addictive
and addictive and bad for you but this
this is even if i have to think about
this
even if i have to go through my life
let's say i do this once a quarter
the rest of my life for five hours
once a quarter really people go to bars
they spend more than that in a bar
drinking alcohol on the weekends
yeah well what what for me uh
like i said i've got you and when you
got it's actually like
how was it man how was how was it and
you were like i
feel freaking awesome now and i was like
okay
i mean like if my friend can escape
this pain and this suffering that you're
in like
i want at least other people know about
it now listen there's like
there's all kinds of things you need to
think about it's
preparation it's making sure you
understand it it's finding the best
doctor the right place
it's it's also having a safety net in
place before you do it because
because it can uncover things that you
didn't think were gonna come
you didn't think this was coming and
guess what you get hit with it and it
will
you get ambushed so you better have some
backup you better have some
safety net you have to assume that
you're gonna need help when you're done
with it
um get in the right environment he uh
tim said
take less than you think you can handle
everyone's like oh i'm just going in
hard
like dumb move yeah dumb move uh
he did also mention a couple places
where there look there's there's john
john hopkins
university johns hopkins university is
is doing
all kinds of experimentation to try and
figure out how to use it properly
there's a bunch of other places that are
doing it as well
there's something called
maps.orgmaps.org
which is the multi-disciplinary
association for psychedelic studies
that's that's this is if you want to
support what we're talking about if you
want to try and get it
so it's not underground right because if
you can go get
prescribed xanax and whatever these
other things that you're talking about
or you can just go down to the freaking
corner store and buy a bottle of whiskey
and inebriate yourself
which all it does is cover up the
problems numbs the problems
if you would like to say hey maybe we
should take a different approach you can
go to maps.org
you can go to usonainstitute.org
it's just another it's u s o n a i
n s t i t u t e
dot org um to try you know to
to donate or whatever you can support
there and then
just universities that are out there
that are doing this
he told me a couple documentaries that
are will help you have better
understanding one of them is called trip
of compassion
and apparently it's super intense
apparently they show
this therapy taking place and it's like
like really intense
and the other one is called fantastic
fungi am i saying that right funky fungi
which is kind of i was kind of like oh
that's kind of it sounds like a uh
whatever
almost a comedic right name and then he
told me what it's about and what it's
about is
they've got people that are have some
kind of terminal disease
in many cases older people but people
that are
people like you what what we're talking
about where people that would never
think about doing anything like this in
their lives and they haven't for
40 60 80 years and
they're they're doing these drugs
in order to overcome or be comfortable
as they face death yeah and something
like he says that there's like grandmas
on there that you know never drank in
their life
and they're on there saying this is the
best thing that i've ever done
so definitely some um
look this again i'm i'm no pro do
research
but it's something that we need to start
talking about
because if it can help us out if it's
been helping people for
a long time anyways you know with the
case of mushrooms been helping for
thousands of years
if there's something if there's a way to
help people let's freaking research it
let's find out how to do it right and
let's let's get people to a situation
where they can do it
um legally but but again doing it
with the right intent yeah
with the right intent and i'm telling
you drinking is way easier
than going in and facing and and working
through
what you see with this drinking is
easier um
going and you know running away from
your problems is way easier this is a
this is a
this is where it's gonna it's gonna look
you in the eyes and you're gonna
if you wanna work on it you'll work on
it i mean and it's so hard it sounds
like even me talking about it
it sounds so crazy just to even talk
about it like that but it's really
like for example the last time i did i
mean i
i i sit there and looked at my teammates
dead
but you know what i looked at in a way
that i was okay with it
i came out of it and i was okay with it
yeah did i still feel the hurt
yeah did was i sad i got to see my
grandparents which i loved
more than anything uh but i was okay
with it
yeah it's okay to to it's a normal
reaction to
to hurt from it to miss them but it's
not normal to let these
actions dictate the rest of your life
and that was where it did it gave me the
perspective of seeing it again on my
terms
and it and hopefully what that did is it
processed it now it's out
check
proceed with caution with caution with
caution
[Music]
um let's talk about something that's a
little less
uh controversial but
also provides a massive amount of
healing in my humble opinion
a little something called jiu-jitsu
how's the jujitsu coming along man you
know i haven't i haven't rolled much
lately
um you know i was rolling quite a bit
whenever
all the the covet hit right everything
got shut down
um i feel like i'll probably be a white
belt for life
um you know um we're all white belts for
life
i yeah i mean i haven't got to roll a
ton lately
i think i rolled maybe like a month ago
but i just i hadn't been able to get
back around to
i mean there's plenty of jiu jitsu to go
on in austin roger that uh tim kennedy
just
fyi your brother here has not been
rolling lately
i'm sure you will uh help remedy that
situation
one of the things that you know for me
jiu jitsu and is
is so important for so many reasons
and it's aligned with the reasons of
like
being in shape working out working out
every day to me that's
[Music]
that's therapy that's therapy right
that's therapy for me
um and i know it's therapy for a lot of
people and i know
hey give me one day for where for
whatever reason
i literally can't work out like whatever
it is like i
i woke up at three o'clock in the
morning to travel and then when i got
home the water he
was broken and i had three clients
calling me and then my kid was sick and
whatever the thing is
it just didn't happen i i i can
feel it right it's like a mental um um
negative emotion that's going on
yeah if i if it's like
seven o'clock at night my wife's about
to serve dinner and i didn't get to work
on i go hey
give me 30 minutes i'm gonna go hammer
one out man
it's like a whole the whole world
changes the whole world
name a time that you've worked out and
you left and you were you're
not happy that you were boy am i bummed
i did that oh man
so fitness huge thing and i i know that
speaking of fitness what's up with this
new freaking like application you got
out
yeah talk to me about this i just uh i
just launched this new so like
i've always wanted look i'm i don't i
don't want to be a bodybuilder
like i have no credibility i don't have
no idea how to even do it right
um i don't want to be a trainer i don't
want to be any of those right but
like i do enjoy the therapy side of
working out of
of of staying in shape of being able to
you know know that that if we get a fire
i can go perform or knowing that i can
get us out you know like i mean i i
still get on a truck to go get after it
right
like i i have to be a dad to my you know
to my daughters and
and look at some point in a few years
when i'm older
they'll be dating boys and i still have
to be able to kick their ass
right so i take that very seriously um
you know so i i still have this
i know how to train and and to me
you know i feel like the closest i
became
all my look look at what all my friends
have in common they all train
you know why because you know where we
got close to our closest friends
suffering and training together right
yeah i mean that's it
and so that's how you build a team i
launched this new app it's on
ownthedashtraining.com
and um you can get on there we got
workouts on there
um you can work out same stuff i do
right
it's not about are you going to get on
there with a program to come out as a
bodybuilder no i don't want to be that
but if you want to get on there and get
after it and have a program you can
follow
to get after it and to be able to leave
and know you did something it's like i
call it practical fitness
it's like you don't it's not complicated
i'm a simple guy i get it done
where i can i like to think it's
efficient you know it's efficient
i just get in what i can with what i got
and that's what it is so you real
quickly like just mentioned oh when i'm
out getting on the truck
because you're a firefighter yeah
firefighter emt i did that last year i
got knocked that out last year because
you know during covet and i was like man
i i really want to get back i really
want to
i really want to i feel like i just i
have more to give like this country has
given me so much people have given me so
much and
i just i feel like i have an obligation
to give and um
i want to do it by being able to put my
hands on people and being able to be
there in their worst moments and so yeah
i went got my certification became an
emt
uh became a firefighter i got my
commission in texas
and um yeah so i um
i was i was paid for probably six months
five
four five six months um and then just my
speeches and stuff started coming back
so i had to get off the truck
you know me and you talked about i mean
it wasn't for everything it was more
about getting experience and
trying to just sharpen that craft and
then you know now i still volunteer and
then
i'm um hopefully i'll i'll start doing
some part-time stuff start picking up
some shifts at this
this uh one of my one of my closest
mentors and uh
in the fire service sam stacks has just
been there for me
the whole time and just kind of led me
through like he's he's like the we call
him the you know you know the white
beards right
like he's like the white beard of the
fire service you know him and
um just been there close friends so
anyways i did that and you know i just
get out there and try to try to help
people when they need it and it's it's
awesome man
i i i've talked to a lot of fire
departments in the country and a lot of
fire departments use the principles from
extreme ownership from dichotomy
leadership from leadership strategy and
tactics we we
we work with these guys a lot and i i
always feel like hey i appreciate what
you guys do
i know it's a hard job i know it's like
a rough job
i know that you see a lot of stuff that
sucks and i know that a lot of it is
like no
like you you you you think of uh
firefighter you think of like
a movie like backdraft where it's like
all kind of
dangerous but heroic it ain't that and
the other part of it that i know exists
is the part that's like
a heroic yes but a different kind of
heroic
and man you and i have had some
conversations about
that that even upped my appreciation
for firefighters and emts even more
when you're talking about just the
day-to-day
yeah life i mean it is yeah let me tell
you
um first off let's let's talk about
police and like uh
ems side of it police paramedics emts
um let me tell you they are the
unsung heroes of this this nation
um the the strain
that is put on our them this system
that we have um the demand from them
they're overworked
they're treated like [ __ ] um on
deployment 365 days a year on deployment
days a year and i'm telling you they are
dealing with
the the peace of the world that we want
to pretend does not exist
and it is here um
respect for them is
if you see a copy or you see a
any of them a first responder
you should thank them and you should
think from the bottom of your heart
for what they do that you don't have to
see um
i had no clue as much as i pretended
like i thought i did
i had no clue the stuff that i see
have seen by just since i've been doing
it
is is worse than anything i've seen in
afghanistan
um on an almost daily basis
yeah i mean look you have shifts that
nothing goes on but you have days where
it sucks
and um yeah it's in
it what they go through is just you you
can't
what what i went through in afghanistan
which i'm not going to say is for
everybody
is what everybody's gone through um but
it can't touch
what i've seen here in
in in the united states and
you know i'll tell you where it really
hit me one time
is whenever i uh i was working on an
ambulance
uh me and my one of my closest friends
um when we
when we pull up and um to a call where a
kid hung himself
and uh i never forget it was like a
hanging and
i'll never forget he looked at me he's
way i mean this dude just you talk about
solid
real he's he's awesome he looked at me
and goes hey make sure when we get out
grab the bolt cutters he's like uh
you never know like if they hung
themself with something other like i've
never even thought about that right
like this guy just and you know you just
you walk in
and you just see you know
you can't this is not war this isn't
somebody shooting at you because they
hate you
i mean this is a kid who was so lonely
that he hung himself
and this is what happens this is
happening in our world
every day has anybody ever thought about
who comes and takes care of this
you know and it's the car wrecks
you know the the
you know it's just it's something that
we try to pretend that doesn't exist
and you got these people who are just
going out and doing this every day i
have no clue as to what they've gone
through i've seen
just about this much of it just a smidge
of it but they go out and they get up in
the middle of night to go
and and be there for when you dial 9-1-1
and it's like these
these people um
not me but these people that i have got
to work with
that i've got to see who have done this
for years like they really
are the real life
batman's superman you look at it like
you know they when you call them they
go and answer whatever needs you need
in the worst moments of your life and
they go back
and they live theirs and they walk the
streets among us and they don't ask for
anything
and it is crazy they are
they are really godsent and it's it's
incredible
and like you know the appreciation i
have for them just getting to work next
to them
um i just i'm honored to just be able to
be around them but it's
you talk about the world
the world right around us
i mean the houses that you walk into
you're just so sad i mean it's
the people you see the overdoses and and
you know you're just like
i'm telling you right now the one thing
that i have
have been able to see is that people are
hurting
people are hurting and uh yeah
but i'll tell you this it's uh it's been
the most fulfilling thing i've done
you know how cool is it to be somebody
to be the person that can show up when
somebody
calls 9-1-1 because they don't know how
to figure it out
how cool is that to be able to come up
on a scene to where everything's chaotic
and they just
need somebody to help them get through
that moment and you get to be that
person right and
and that's where i think like my
perspective has changed on all this like
with my teammates or with all the people
i've seen die and
and all this like you know what's kind
of cool is man is is
i um for some reason i keep getting put
in these positions
and it's an honor because i get to be
the person that's there with them as
their soul leaves their body
and how cool is that to be able to share
that moment with somebody
their last moments on this earth i ge
sometimes i get to share that with them
these people and it's an
honor like i walk away and does it
bother me of course it bothers me
but like now i i get to say hey you know
what it was an honor
it was an honor that you shared that
moment with me whether you
obviously didn't choose to but obviously
we're here for a reason and um
i get to do this and it is like
it's awesome it is awesome
it's awesome
i've been uh lucky enough to work with
uh police departments
around the country and and what's
interesting about what you were saying
is that
like you said it's underneath the
surface right and i think when you see
something on the news
you know you see a shooting on the news
or a suicide or an
overdose we have a tendency to think
that it's somewhere else
yeah it's someone else and i'm telling
you
small towns big towns cities
country rural north south
east west you don't have to
go very far quote beneath the surface
because by the way
socioeconomic class doesn't matter
you go to rich people's houses you go to
poor people's houses you go to the
projects
and there's there's people that are
uh in their worst moments in their worst
moments
and um
like you said it's the it's these uh
first responders that are out there
that they they answer that call
every time every single time every
single time
and they do it for years
they do it for years and on end
and it is like watching them you know
just
like literally they prepare
for the unknown they never know what the
call is going to be
like they literally wake up every day to
be
whatever you need them to be when they
need to be it and i'm telling you
and they do it and they do it they're
it's such a like police especially likes
police
such a thankless job obviously right now
right and they're out there doing their
best and they're out there
just trying to trying to to to be what
people need them to be
and at the end of the day they're no
different than you are
they're a mother they're a sister
they're a father
they're a son they're no different than
you are the only difference is is that
they chose to put a badge on to go serve
other people that's it
they're not they're not some trained
robot
they're not some person who is you know
was
was born with all these mind-reading
activities or
can breed the future to know if
someone's going to kill them tonight
they are just like you are they are as
scared as you are
they they don't want to do like they got
their own problems at home
and guess what they do they choose to
set theirs aside
and and they don't let me tell you up
front they don't do it for the pay
they do not do it for the pay they
they they don't do that no they do it
because they care about people
i don't care their intent
they don't stay in that job without good
intent
it's not possible it is not possible it
ain't worth it
it is not worth it
but it's awesome man it's awesome like
it's just awesome like i i would get on
a truck with these guys and i would just
look at them and all
of just like no matter how chaotic it
got
they they had it and it was like this is
awesome
i want to be one of them how often do
you walk around and say that
i want to be one of them it's badass
they're a badass
salute uh you mentioned a couple times
today
the new book yeah the new book coming
out tell us about the new book
the way forward um
yeah so i wrote a book you know me and
rob
o'neal we speak for the same um
speaking agency me and rob connected on
not necessarily about like combat stuff
but just more about
the just life right we both come from
small towns
we both are somewhere that neither one
of us
you know ever thought we would be right
you know and um
we both have stuff that haunts us and
that was kind of where we connected of
like how do we put a book together
kind of talking about
giving some perspective
that we're no different than anybody
else you know that's the one thing that
i always
felt like a lot of these war books came
back
like right after you know these war
books came out and i feel like
all the way up until chris kyle's movie
there wasn't really that humanization
piece right in chris kyle's movie
they they showed more of the when he was
coming back home between deployments the
struggle sometimes right
and i think that was the first time in
any of the movies that it ever really
hit
and you know i always felt like in our
books that we wrote we
we built ourselves up to be something
great but we never showed that
we never humanized the factors of war
and you know that was a piece that
always got me
and uh what kind of like when i came
home
and so like you know in the way forward
it's just about it's about life like a
lot of stories i told today
you know the ibogaine story is in there
right like the
you know the the story i talk about my
grandpa you know just about
you know the the circle i talk about my
circle and why i talk about tim kennedy
the story i told you
i i put that in there about how like
between tim shane and
brandon uh my friends about how like
um you know you you got the sword the
shield and the armor
right and and those are like that
um how each of them fit and you know i
talk about
you know my struggles in alaska i talk
about not you know about like
my divorce i talk you know i talk about
all this and i talk about more of the
human
side of it to humanize
about who we are and you know and i
think it's going to be great it comes
out in july
and i think it's going to be great
because you know i think it's coming at
a
probably a good time in the country of
where people are looking for
a way forward right and that's kind of
where it
where it comes around so what's the
layout what's the
normally as you know i read books before
people come on
here but in this case you handed it to
me today and said got a new book coming
out so uh what's the format of it
so basically in each chapter um rob
tells a story
i tell a story for each chapter for each
chapter is there a common theme between
yeah yeah so like if you look at like if
you you know when you read it
i can't i haven't looked at it because
uh you know what you didn't give it to
me until today so uh
that's your tricky way of getting back
here again yeah you know
you like that right um so you know you
talk about like american boys like
that's the first chapter taking
aim um find your heroes um
you know drilling open your eyes like
you know i talk about i kind of
you know like one of the stories i talk
about in here that i felt like
you know my cousin stephen was i mean
you talk about a guy who was always
there for me right
and uh especially one of my biggest
cheerleaders when i went to the marine
corps
and um man when i came back and i was
just in that
this dark mode um
you know he had he had a kid and married
and all this
and like he got busy right and you know
he just wasn't answering the phone
and i took it as well he's like leaving
me
leaving me hanging right but really now
that i'm a father
i get it um
so me and him got into it pretty bad and
like
i tell you i
over it just because of ego and
resentment um
i invited everybody in my family except
him to the medal of honor ceremony
and uh you know man i
that's one of the dudes that stood by me
the whole time you know
and uh just just stuff like that like
lessons of
hopefully if i can't meet somebody that
they can read this book and
and maybe it touches their life to say
hey you know what maybe i'm doing this
in my life right now before i go and
and mess it up even worse you know maybe
you can look at this as a little bit of
perspective
that maybe maybe some mentorship
you know um but yeah it's just all
stories about
that that you should be able you know
everybody could relate to whether you
served in combat or you didn't
and rob's is the same way you know rob's
is talking about
um basketball about growing up and you
know
you montana i mean rob has got some
funny stories i'm laughing because
um rob and i were on deployment it was
like 99 or 2
000. and i don't even think we
had aimed we went to the gym to work out
and there was some dudes playing
basketball and i played basketball i
sucked
like i played basketball in high school
you know when i was a point guard so i
could like dribble i had some ball
handling skills i could pass and whatnot
but i would like get more steals in the
game than i would points
right partially because of my position
but partially because i i and i was
like i was a hustler right i would be
i'd every game i'd leave with like skin
knees and skin elbow because i dive on
every ball
well well rob's like uh he played a
little bit of college ball
and being from montana most of the time
you find with people that are from the
north
they're really good at shooting because
you know you can't dribble in the
wintertime
so you just sit out there and shoot
shoot hoops so he could he could
he could shoot yeah and we're like
walking across you know in our running
she's ready to go work out and there's
some guys
you know playing some ball and we had
one i think we had one or two other guys
with us
and you know rob you know constantly
talking [ __ ] to everybody you know he
said something like oh nice shot you
know and the dudes were like oh you guys
want some
and rob's like yeah yeah and you know
these kids were wearing you know air
jordans
like they were like they were ready to
run some game on us yeah
nike shots yeah yeah nike shocks and
stuff and rob
i mean i get no you he's a little taller
right what's he six one piece yeah six
foot six one
yeah maybe six once but you're not
looking at him thinking he's a baller
especially he's like you know
a pale white dude with red hair and you
know
so they're looking at us like oh these
nerds yeah and sure enough man
like it's a great combo because i could
i had good ball handling
and i could just i was just feeding him
and he's just hitting jump shot jump
shot outside shot jumped out we just
destroyed him
and we walked off with rob still talking
[ __ ] yeah
you know like yeah i mean you know i um
i love rob death uh great guy
um you know he's he's always been i'll
tell you what he's been one of my
biggest cheerleaders
um yeah and it was just it was
we wrote this book together i think it's
you know it's going to be good you know
hopefully it gets out there and helps
people and
yeah you know it's going to be awesome
right on well i look forward to uh
reading it now that i have a copy
yeah what else what's the future what
else you got coming up
you know i you know getting
you know get we're gonna do this book
tour starting july um
we're out there we're uh pushing the
discipline go
right the best flavor there is dax
savage oh that's right just so you know
dak savage um dax have you so you got
your own energy drink is what i'm
hearing
well i don't i have my own flavor yes
okay well it's kind of amazing
jack savage you know um it's uh
when's the tour taking place july july
and then what are you go
you guys are going to different cities
yeah so you know we're well i guess
we'll
see right i mean we're waiting for
because of miss rona well yeah i mean
you know i guess they're like they're
doing virtual book signings so we're
going to have those going but
but you know me and rob both have talked
that we want to get on the road like we
want to go out and see people i want to
honestly man i just want to go
and get around people and and be able to
fire people up get them excited about
life again you know get them excited
look it's going to be all right like
we're going to
we're going to get through this you know
get out get out of the tv
get get out of get get turn turn the
news off get off get off
social media and um stop believing what
people tell you and just look around and
believe what you see
right and um yeah so that that's that's
that you know that's kind of
that's kind of what we're doing crushing
it well before we jump into the support
i kind of wanted to wrap this up
um bringing it back to to colonel
charles
whittlesey whittlesey um
so at his memorial service there was a
a friend of his family this is in
pittsfield massachusetts they had a
memorial service
and this family friend
who is also a judge a guy by the name of
charles
hibbard he uh
he delivered the the eulogy
and this is what he said quote
we can sit here and say
he had so much to live for family
friends and all that makes
life sweet
but no my friends
life span for him was measured those
days
in that distant forest
he had plumbed the depth of tragic
suffering
he had heard the world's applause
he had seen and touched the great
realities of life
and what remained was of little
consequence
he craved rest peace
and sweet forgetfulness
he thought it out quietly serenely
confidently minutely
he came to a decision not lightly or
unadvisedly
and in the end did what he thought was
best
and in the comfort of that
we too must rest
end quote and
i disagree
i don't think we can rest i don't think
we should rest i think we must not rest
what i think we should do is help
i think we need to help
our veterans that are suffering
and and not just veterans but people
from all
walks of life because
life is hard
and no matter who you are
you either are facing or you will be
facing
disappointment
and despondency
and loss
but don't give up
just you got to keep fighting
you got to get out of that echo chamber
that your head is trapped in
you got to build relationships with
people
then you gotta move forward
not just for yourself but for the people
around you
so let's not rest
let's help
thanks for coming on man well thanks for
having me and you know like like
with what you're saying on you know that
that end quote i agree
and i tell people all the time um
you do matter you do
like the biggest lies you biggest lies
that are told are the ones you tell
yourself
and and you know what just as the good
times
they don't all last forever neither do
the bad
and you do matter you do matter somebody
somewhere
is relying on you somebody somewhere
whether you've met them yet or not they
will be relying on you
and you do matter and i'm with you
look it's there's nothing weak about it
there's nothing
struggle is struggle you know a lot of
times people they see us
as as that that you know
we don't struggle or we don't have hard
days because we don't necessarily walk
around and talk about all the time
but like the hardest even the hardest
people on earth
they got hard not because easy times
they got hard because of hard days and
they got through it
and it's a choice and you just have to
continue
to choose to get through it and it's
worth it
indeed thanks for having me
yeah man
it's a freaking honor to have you on
here echo charles
yes sir i'm not quite
one hundred percent sure that it's an
honor for me to have you on here but
it's pretty cool
okay oh
it's an honor oh thank you thank you
dakota meyer it's always an honor for me
to be in your presence yeah that's very
very big pleasure for you
we want to help ourselves we want to
help others
what do you recommend select what do you
mean hey do you still uh fight your
helicopter
i i sold it but i'm getting another one
are you getting like a
better one i don't know or just a
different one just a different one why
was that no good
he's like no better one like they only
have like
they only have like so many hours was
that one getting close to the end
yeah what do you mean like like a
projector light bulb kind of thing well
like
after like so many hours they have to be
rebuilt yeah yeah
what model was that one that you had r44
raven 2
and those are like very common yeah
they're like the toyota corolla of
helicopters yeah
yeah what's funny is i thought of this
video idea a while ago like last year
so like let's do it now he's in the
execution phase now
so he he likes to he like well it's too
bad you sold it no no i got i got
my buddies we got like four or five of
them out there so okay let's do it
well i gained access to a 3d model of
your helicopter
and and i saw little videos of it so i'm
like and so i made it look like yours so
i was going to do something but
i didn't do it yet but you know he's
been incubating the
idea for a year that's what kind of you
know
activity we got going on over there i'm
still doing my research
hey the last podcast that just came out
um
it's two i think it's 275.
yeah 275 helicopter pilot from vietnam
and
they're the best you you usually check
it out for sure
because he's just flying that huey and
we kind of got more into the like
just questions about like flying that
thing and how hard it is to fly a
helicopter
and there was one quote in there his dad
was a master chief in the navy
so this guy's a freaking warrant officer
or whatever warrant officer two
yeah and his dad is a master chief in
the nate who was imagining became like
lieutenant commander in the navy
and then goes to see him or oh no
he's stationed in saigon the dad's in
saigon like we're doing some
bureaucratic
whatever logistics thing and the sun's
up freaking flying ops every day
he goes and picks up his dad and brings
him up to
wherever they were out in the bush and
starts flying missions with his dad his
dad's on the 50
it's like this has like 45 years old
like a lieutenant commander
up there just get they get into
firefights bro his dad's on the 50 cal
anyways his dad says to him like after a
couple days he goes you know i
i work with a lot of air force guys and
those air force those
jet fighter pilots you know they're
always so positive they're always having
such a good time
and you guys are all miserable and
walking around like everything's
horrible
what's up with that and he says well dad
uh air force fighter pilot is flying an
aircraft that wants to fly
that that if you don't do anything it's
kind of gonna just keep flying
yeah he goes we're flying something that
doesn't want to fly it wants to crash
and if we don't balance these four
different things
it's going to go down and we're close
enough the ground that people are
shooting at us with machine guns and
rpgs and
everything else on top of it so you want
to know why we're freaking stressed
that's why
next question next question dad
you talk about a father-son relationship
after that dude
freaking crazy right it's crazy hey dad
i'm gonna come pick you up and i'm gonna
take you on to run some they did three
days of operations
that's crazy his dad shot and look
is that shot a 50 cal he was shooting a
50 cal out of the
out of the huey that's gotta move a huey
a little bit don't you think
like like you're moving a little bit i
don't know i mean
no they got so much power yeah yeah like
those things are
yeah damn but the thing is like
they they do but it's weird talking to
him
it's the first time that i really got
the feeling of like
man how in touch with those aircraft
those guys were yeah like you
you can't be reactive like it's like
balancing yourself on a beach ball
yeah and it's part of them yeah they
flew to the point where it's part of
them
and so that's why i say like when the
like there'd be like a little thing like
uh
they could tell like how much weight
they had on they're like oh we're a
hundred pounds heavy
like how do you tell you're a hundred
pounds heavy on a freaking helicopter
yeah they could they were just they just
knew everything and they were so in
touch with those birds
it's freaking nuts man yeah it's the
power load yeah how much power it takes
to come off oh yeah
freaking crazy yeah um yeah
awesome so echo charles yeah
trying to get better yes trying to be
better
what do you recommend well well let's
start with uh
these illustrious healthy energy drinks
you know we don't all have our own
flavor
maybe some of us do some of us don't
know maybe some of us
but either way flavor whichever flavor
these are good things
tell us about uh it was kind of
interesting how did you how did you end
up
with this who'd you talk to
you oh it was me
[Laughter]
since you're still in touch man i don't
remember man
i don't know would you call me up and
say i should have my own flavor
no no you you said it after i
oh i got rhabdo on the other energy
drink
right and you're like i was like oh
that's right i remember saying bro you
can't be drinking that stuff
what's in it it's this this this this i
went through everything like bro
let me send you some real [ __ ] yeah and
then you're like we'll make your own
flavor yeah then i said what flavor do
you want
what flavor do you like do you see how
did he forget
what are you gonna ask he's got a lot on
his plate i remember that now
i remember that now uh but i remember
saying like what flavor do you like are
you like i like dr
pepper i was like okay all right
we can work with that because that's a
cult following dr pepper
it is people is a cult following but who
wants to drink
uh uh high fructose corn syrup
who wants to drink that well probably
nobody if they knew the reality
nobody wants to drink so
what we're talking about is this drink
right here well
his drink is called dak savage
dax savage it is
black cherry vanilla it's totally
healthy for you
how many did you drink you just drank
three i drank three two
you guys are fired up man hey
that's cool we have to drink three to
stay on your level i don't know man
i don't know i can't even remember that
i had conversation with you about this
all right so we got we got these awesome
drinks if you want to get one go to get
some go to jacofuel.com
and you can order them you can also get
them from wawa
on out on the east coast by the way wawa
put like put the brakes on me a little
bit
they're like slow your roll well because
people were like going in there and
buying
all of them and we had to get our supply
chain caught back
up supply chain is caught back up so
roll on
roll go get some clear those shelves
savage yeah jack savage that savage is
your flavor
uh yeah so there you go what else
interesting these drinks is like one of
those things where it's like oh yeah i'm
trying to improve let me do a
i don't know a pre-workout we'll call it
a a traditional
pre-workout energy drink scenario that's
technically i mean it's that's like a
short term
a very on the path thing with long-term
detriments yeah i was to say
it's not just short term like oh but i
feel good for a minute no and now i
legitimately am going backwards i'm less
healthy
literally less healthy yeah don't do
that this is not like that
this is short term and long term
straight up straight up
tactical and strategic victory yeah
it's like you know you know those
combination ancient combination locks on
those
old school movies i don't know indiana
jones i don't know
one of these deals i've seen but but
it's impossible to do it's actually not
on indiana jones i don't think
maybe it is either way it's it's like
that you figured out the combination
yeah that's the short term and the long
term and it's healthy and it tastes good
damn interesting thank you yeah
absolutely incredible metaphor
also speaking of tasting good we got
some additional protein supplementation
called monk
i've been on that i've been on the train
this past week i have been too actually
hey is this a is it a violation and i
always have actually
well you know how oh guys i got a sweet
i got a sweet tooth
okay is this i like deletion let me put
it that way you i don't think you've
done this but
this may have been done from other
people other than just me
put dark chocolate chips in the molk
come on no i haven't done that but i've
done probably something equally
what is it is this a violation you think
yeah that's the question yeah i don't
think it's a violation but i have put
ice cream
straight up into my mold yeah we'll say
it's not a violation but you're pushing
it
here's the thing i did it and i was like
okay it wasn't worth it yeah it kind of
yeah
oh yeah it's going to be no the reason
for milk is because it already tastes
like dessert
it's like can you have something can
dessert taste
more like dessert no really in my
opinion yes like
like i don't know if you like rocky road
ice cream but let's say
marshmallows i'm gonna okay all right
cool i dig it man but what if let's see
s'mores no okay marshmallows no however
lucky charms back in the district
see jacquard just eating the freaking
mushrooms out of the lucky charms you're
that guy bro
you know i take the milk and what i do
is i mix water with it
and i put in a bowl in the morning and
i'll mix water with it and then i'll
like make a pudding out of it and i'll
put it in the uh
i just i'll do it first thing in the
morning and then i'll put it in the
refrigerator and then when i come home
in the evening i eat it like that oh
it's like pudding it's interesting hey
so you're just telling me this right now
so basically you just like
you can't put too much water so you just
put it like you just put like a little
bit of water in there and then see if it
mixes it up and if you need just a
little bit more
you put it in there until it's basically
like uh like mud
like mud and then you stick it in the
refrigerator
and it is listen what flavor to you what
flavor do you do
well so i i like i mean i love the
pumpkin
the pumpkin is like it's like pumpkin
pie he just looked like an
addict when he said that he's like i
like the pumpkin
we talked about the toe the dmt toad
earlier you look
that does make sense though because if i
don't add enough whether it be milk you
know when you make it in the blender the
normal way
if i put a little bit of peanut butter
in it though sometimes
so i've even in the peanut butter flavor
yes sir okay
sometimes you're gonna od on peanut
butter but it's all good it's very
possible
but there had been times where i didn't
put enough milk or i put too many scoops
in there
and yeah after i blended it up i was
like oh this is kind of like almost like
a pudding
now you need to throw it now throw it in
the fridge put it in the fridge
oh it's listen you'll call me after you
do that
and we'll say thank you praise be to
dakota
so boom again another another uh
short-term
long-term payoff situation right there
tactical strategic victory
yes sir yes sir yes so yes go to jackal
field that's where you can get all this
stuff chocofuel.com
vitamin shop you can get a vitamin shop
too oh yes if you need to get it
boom local yep also there's some other
cool supplements on there vitamin d3
joint warfare super krill oil for your
joints we don't want to worry about that
kind of stuff
we don't want to worry about getting
sick no let your immune system worry
about that and you just worry about your
immune system
give it vitamin d3 you don't worry about
that stuff anymore that's my point you
feel me seeing what you see what i'm
saying anyway you can get this stuff
also
at originusa.com yeah
there's a lot of stuff on originusa.com
by the way aside from choco fuel
supplements
which is american-made geez
geez rashcards jiu-jitsu rashcards or
other
purposes do you what do you use a rash
guard for uh
so i mean i don't usually wear a rash
guard but i wear those shorts
as underwear oh damn let me tell you
something which ones
well either which ones yeah the uh i
mean the
one because there's like the actual
underwear oh
dyke not those no the ones like that
have the uh
the constitution on them oh yeah yeah
yeah american flag yeah
yeah yeah those are well yeah those are
those are supposed to be underwear bro
oh so you're actually using them in the
correct manner
yeah where underwear is underwear what
happens when you roll it what happens
when you roll in them
without underwear oh that's so let me
stretch
really yeah okay hey
yeah he's the man so yeah that's great
i'm glad he's the man
um here's the deal like in the early
jujitsu days there was like this thing
in brazil where they would wear like
it's called the song it's called a
sangha and then there's a lot
a longer one is called a sangao but a
shorter one's called like a sangha it's
basically a freaking pair of speedos
and dean had something like that sort of
like in between the two
like but they're freaking basically hot
pants
yeah i mean it's basically a speedo and
and he'd roll with me you know
and like you know i'm gonna see if i can
get a pair and it's just a freaking
nightmare
and i'm glad that those things went out
of style
how is it passing the guard uh dude it's
just awesome
hey tell you what it's not as bad as
north south i'll tell you that
it's a freaking nightmare like you want
to talk
about ptsd bro probably better i got
freaking
a damn animal male animal and a pair of
white
tighty whities freaking all up on me
yeah
north south with him on top either way
bro
but at least at least if i'm on top i
can maneuver like
i'm going cross side neon belly i might
even just run away
nightmares i need ibogaine to freaking
recover from that
mentally scarred well yeah i think
you're right about that
by the way also at origin main we got
some
american-made denim jeans boots
boom anyway check that out it's a good
spot
also jocko has a store it's called jocko
stores where you can get shirts
hats hoodies lightweight and regular
heavy-ish weight
hoodies this one equals freedom good
all this stuff when you want to
represent while you're on this path boom
that's
that's the place to get your stuff we
also have a a subscription scenario
going on it's called the shirt locker
it's a good one new shirt every month
different designs they're interesting
i saw someone was hyped on social media
about that
yeah oh yeah best thing ever they had
the all your excuses little eyes
t-shirt that's a good one you came up
with that
i respect you for it deeply but yeah
that's a good one
look at that when it bounced for you hey
check uh get that it's good
chocostore.com uh we also have some
podcasts
what's your status with your podcast so
i'm doing so me and dan holloway
do the american party podcast the
american party podcast
so what happened to front toward enemy
so when covet hit i just couldn't get
guests in uh
that kind of like okay so you're back in
the game with dan what's it called
the american party podcast so basically
we just kind of talk about
like what's going on in the world and we
you know
put common sense logic um sometimes
those things are good with the
situations that are going on right now
right on right on awesome so check that
out
how many how many how long have you been
doing that for since like november
okay so it's so that's right around when
you stop i think your last episode of
front tournament
came out and then we just rolled right
into that yeah because it just
like i couldn't get into like
interviewing people over
zoom zoom when i was like i'm out yeah
that's different
it's different it's hard to connect with
them yeah i've done a couple of them not
for this one we're trying to maintain
the live situations i've done a bunch of
zoom and
look it's zoom is zoom is real close
depending on what you're going to talk
about if people are just going to talk
about you know whatever some
whatever like not totally surface
topics but if you're not going deep you
know yeah we're good
yeah i'll do zoom if you're if you're
doing an interview like maybe a standard
for like a better term interview
like hey this is going on what do you
feel about this dakota meyer then then
we wait for dakota maya's answer oh yeah
okay hard to have a conversation
exactly right exactly right so check out
that uh podcast from dakota also
we you can subscribe to this podcast if
you want
and echo used to seem to think that
there was a lot of people that were like
purposely not
subscribing
the look on your face when i when i
ascribe when i when i put thoughts into
your head
turns into your mouth i'm trying to you
look so puzzled because you look like
you you trust me
again and so you got to look on your
face like wait did i really do that no
okay anyways that's me trying to recall
when i that's what i'm saying give you
that impression
trust me you trust me that i'm that i'm
not sitting here just making things up
which i just did
yeah so yeah all right so echo never
said that anymore trust is broken
[Music]
if you want to subscribe to this podcast
go ahead and do it leave a review or
whatever i also have a
jocko unraveling podcast with daryl
cooper new one just came out
they're they're freaking
it's a good place to learn grounded
podcast about jujitsu warrior kid
podcast some new episodes just dropped
so you can check that out if you want we
also have the jocko
underground dot-com
sure which is a another it's it's look
what it is it's a way for us to build a
network that we don't have to rely on
anybody else we have to run out of
platforms we don't have to rely on any
advertising nothing like that
so if you want to help out you want to
support you can go to
jockowunderground.com you can join that
and as a as a thank you we do another
freaking podcast and answer questions
i'm and now i'm starting to cover little
topics yeah little
some good toughness little topics to
give people some perspective
because because not everything is a
jackal podcast
right there's a certain you first of all
you can't have a jackal podcast really
that's like
18 minutes long yeah you could but it
wouldn't
be what people are expecting and
normally
we don't like to do that so we made this
other podcast talking about different
topics educational topics
life topics it's not all about to do
with war and all that stuff it's not all
all the leadership it's
but but it of course it does include
those things as well so anyways
if you want to check that out how's this
for a topic yeah you
can see your opinion it's my preliminary
thought i think i might have sent it to
you might not have
the fights you used to get into not like
as an adult but you know like
as a kid you know like you get into like
your first fight
what was that oh yeah and then go up
through high school i mean
i don't know i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
put i don't know what your
actual experience is but i thought of it
because i was talking with my wife and
she like reminded me of something that i
said it and then she was like oh you're
this bad kid
and then i'm like yeah well when you
condense all the fights i ever got in in
my life
it kind of seemed like i was this bad
kid but it was kind of interesting to
kind of go
through those in like debris compare yes
like you compare your mindset like as a
kid
and then versus as a as an adult yeah i
got some
yeah that's interesting that's literally
the next thought i had was like i wonder
if like
because you know how you you went
through like some stuff
yeah you know with the especially in the
hardcore scene and all this stuff
yeah and then it's like it's a different
that's a different community we'll say
yeah yeah it's weird to look back at
those days it's very strange to look
back at those days now
yeah very strange so it's like yeah
that'd be really interesting because
it's just a different
like what you were saying earlier dakota
about being just younger
yeah i mean when i was like 15
like my whole partially developed brain
it's just filled with testosterone and
rage
uh we got some interesting topics on
there so if you want to uh
it costs money eight dollars and
eighteen cents a month again this is how
we're building a contingency plan in
case
things go sideways we'll still have a
way to get this information out
if you can't afford that it's all good
we got you just email assistance at
underground at jocko underground.com and
we'll hook it up
it's true we got a youtube channel it's
official
official it's called jocko podcast is
that what it's called
it's called chocopodcast and the good
videos on there
i am the assistant director of okay so
you can check those out hey origin also
origin has a little uh
has a channel hd a little hd that they
put out if you want to know what's
happening up at origin
as we rebuild america and i'll say what
pretty soon it looks like it could be
also if you want to see what's going on
down there with origin
because we won't be expanding in some
other states some other opportunities
are out there
so we continue to bring back
manufacturing not just to maine
not just to new england but to america
at large
which is what we're looking to do it's
true also psychological warfare is an
album that we put out a few years ago by
the way
still doing well what it does is what
you do is you listen to these tracks
of jocko letting you know how to get
past these moments of weakness if
they come about which works probably
well they will from time to time for
sure
and if you might want a visual
representation of
maybe how to overcome some weakness you
can go to
flipsidecanvas.com that's right
flipside canvas where you can get all
your motivation you need to hang up
anywhere you can um you can do canvas
prints
we have infused metal um
we have or you can just get a you know
like a poster like a
it's all the motivation you need who
owns that company
i know them hey dakota has a company you
hear me talk about
every episode flipsidecanvas.com
where'd you come up with the name flip
side you know the last thing that might
uh that kenofix said to me um
when he kicked off that morning he said
uh meyer i'll see you on the flip side
and um that's where the name came from
you know flip side canvas
just trying to do do another little part
of changing the world the same thing
that he stepped off to do that day
and um yeah that's where it comes from
to motivate to be able to inspire people
you know
um you know i figured out like when we
look at something
you know we when we view something it
makes us feel a certain way
it's connected you know our eyes are
connected right to our soul
and then um you know so that's where the
art came from of like how do we
put things out to where people see this
and feel something that inspires them
and that's that's where flipside comes
from and also
on top of all that once again bringing
manufacturing back to america because
it's all made all made in america
austin texas made in austin austin texas
go to flipsidecanvas.com check out all
the cool designs and stuff that you can
hang on
on your wall got a bunch of books
obviously into the fire which was
dakota's first book
his new book along along with rob o'neal
it's called the way forward so you can
pre-order that thing right now
that way you can get your first a dish a
dish
uh you can get my novel what jocko write
a novel about oh you write about some
war thing no he wrote it about a laundry
mat
he wrote it about a 1982 buick century
wagon
he wrote it about a big box store and he
wrote it about
brotherhood brotherhood so if you want
to check that out
check that out it's coming out in
november and by the way if you pre-order
you'll get a first edition if you don't
you're not getting first a dish because
there's no way that my publisher thinks
that
people are going to buy this they're
like oh you know he's uh who's this guy
he's like he wrote
right yeah who's gonna buy a novel he's
a knuckle dragger
cool you keep thinking that
if you want to get that first to dish
order up finals
otherwise approach when you approach me
with your second third addition
it is brutal guess what it's not getting
signed approach me with a bowed head
i'll sign it
but bow your head bow your head in shame
don't watch me while i sign this
yeah bow your head in shame because you
didn't get in the game early enough
the book is called final spin laundry
mats
station wagons and brotherhood
sacrifice
it's a poem possibly i just had to i
just did the final edits
oh dude okay i gotta start reading
little chunks of that thing on here
get it get people all right um
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual code evaluations protocols
disciplinary freedom field manual weigh
the warrior kid one two three and four
mikey and the dragons about faced by
colonel david hackworth
i wrote the forward on the new edition
extreme ownership dichotomy leadership
the og of jocko books that i wrote with
my brother lee favin
we got echelon front leadership
consultancy where we solve problems
through leadership go to
echelonfront.com for details we got ef
online
just coming at you got a bunch of new
courses that we just put up
that that get granular on the leadership
principles
we talk about all the time we got the
musters we are executing the muster
orlando may 25th and 26th
phoenix august 17th and 18th
las vegas october 28th and 29th
everything that we've ever done has sold
out so
if you want to come you gotta you gotta
get register early extremeownership.com
to check those out we got ef battlefield
coming up
if you want to walk the hallowed grounds
at the battle of gettysburg and learn
the lessons
from history that came from that battle
go to echelonfront.com events and
register it's like
30 people or 35 people we sold out the
first one we opened up another one
it's battlefield walk the battlefield we
have dinner we have lunch we have q a
face to face it's like you want to come
and and
you want to come and squeeze my brain
for info
come to that thing and then if you want
to help service members
active and retired their families gold
star families you can check out
mark lee's mom mama lee she's got a
charity organization if you want to
donate or you want to get involved
go to americasmightywarriors.org
if you want more of my bona fide
blathering
or you need more of echoes cumbersome
communications
you can find us on the interwebs on
twitter instagram
which echo only refers to as the gram
and facebook
echoes with charles i am at a jocko
willink dakota
first of all you have a website which is
dakotamyer.com
how do we get the app uh go to
ownthedashtraining.com can you search
for it on a
apple store or whatever uh you have to
go you got to go through on the desk
training
okay so send you an email you'll get all
of it
go to on the dash own training.com
also you are on facebook dakota meyer
you're on the gram the gram at dakota
meyer
oh and you're on twitter
at dakota underscore
echo anything else that's it good to see
you again as always
so good to see you that was
right not to even hurt me already well
you know he's a genuine guy i like it
good good energy the intent of that was
really rough as he holds that knife
there yeah kind of odd
dakota anything else any clothing
closing thoughts well thank you for
having me on it's always good to see you
yeah man for sure uh thanks for coming
back
and thanks for coming back and thanks
for continuing to try and
help make all of us a little bit better
i know every time i
every time i hear you every time i talk
to you i feel like you're making me a
little bit better
and you know more important thanks for
your
for your service and and thanks for
setting the example
for the next generation the next
generation
i appreciate it i appreciate you i
appreciate you answering the calls
appreciate you answering the phone yeah
i appreciate it
it's an honor it makes me nervous but
it's an honor
um you know but the next generation of
sailors
soldiers airmen marines they need to
have
people to look look to and you're
you're that guy and um
to those to those that are out there
right now that are
protecting us on the front lines around
the world protecting our most sacred
gift which is freedom itself
thanks for holding the line and and to
our people in uniform here at home and
we know who those are that's police and
law enforcement that's firefighters and
paramedics and emts and dispatchers and
correctional officers and border patrol
and secret service
all the first responders
thank you for being there when we call
9-1-1
and everyone else out there
remember that life is hard and no matter
who you are you're going to face
challenges you're going to face
vicious challenges at some point you're
going to be let down and you're going to
let people down
you're going to have failures and then
you're going to have
more failures you're going to be
uncomfortable and you're going to be
alone and every one of you
out there all of us
we're going to lose somebody that we
love
that's the way life is
that's what life is and through all of
that
just remember that you have to get up
remember to give thanks for what you do
have remember to give thanks for what
you can do
and remember that your worst day is
someone else's dream
and like dakota says
our last living legacy is a tombstone
and that tombstone has your name and it
states the day you were born and it
states the day you died
but what really matters is that little
dash in between
that's your life
that is your life so go out there
and live it
and until next time this is dakota meyer
and echo and jocko out